GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME
OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. TODAY
WE HAVE TWO MEMBERS WHO WILL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY THAT
WOULD BE SENATOR PACKER. AND
SENATOR GLAZER. DID I SEE-
CENTER LOW MOAN- REMOTELY AS
WELL YEAH I THOUGHT SO ANSWER
REMOTE IF SO CAN YOU PLEASE-
YOU SEE. THAT'S CENTER BECKER
GLAZER OR LIMóN DO YOU HAVE
STAFF- IN YOUR OFFICE. LET'S
START WITH THAT SENATOR GLAZERS.
THIS IS SENATOR GLAZER I DO NOT
HAVE ANY STAFF HERE IN MY
OFFICE THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZERS. CENTER BACKER. I DO
NOT HAVE ANY STEP IN IN THE
OFFICE. THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER
BECKER- CENTER LIMóN. I AM
PRESENTING TODAY AND DO NOT
HAVE ANY STAFF IN THE OFFICE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
MORNING. OKAY FOR THOSE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AS
REMINDER PLEASE MEET YOUR PHONE
OR COMPUTER. THIS WILL GREATLY
AID IN ELIMINATING ANY C<c.cyan></c>
FEEDBACK I S. IT EVERY TIME YOU
WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED FUTURE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO UNMUTE.
PLEASE SELECTOR I NEED BUT
BEFORE SPEAKING R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND WHEN
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
IT WILL BE USING TELECONFERENCE
SERVICES FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. THAT'S.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE. IS EIGHT SEVEN SIX. EIGHT
NINE FOUR ONE. EIGHT SEVEN SIX
EIGHT NINE FOUR ONE FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES FROM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
PRESS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LNE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
UNMUTE IT AND YOU ARE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS OUR COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THIS HEARING
THAT IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONVERSATION MUTED. WELL EVERY
EFFORT IS MADE TO STREAMLINE
THE HEARING PROCESS. AND
CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS. IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS.
WHO ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW
USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
WE HAVE A LEVIN BILLS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY. FOR WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS LET
US ESTABLISH A QUORUM. MEMBERS
REMINDER TO PLEASE WAIT A TO
YOUR MICROPHONE IS TURNED ON
AND SPEAK INTO THE MICROPHONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DOT HERE DOT HERE NIELSEN OKAY
SO NIELSEN HERE ALLEN. ALLEN
HERE ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA HERE
BECKER HERE BAKER HERE BARGES.
BORDERS HERE BRADFORD. GLAZER
THE SENATOR GLAZER PRESENT
GLAZER HERE WHAT'S SO RESIDENTS
WEST OF HERE JONES HERE JONES
HERE MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ HERE
PORTANTINO HERE PORTANTINO HERE
RUBIO. AT THE RIVER HERE
WELCOME. WELL HERE WE HAVE A
CURRENT TERM. THE SECRETARY
NOTES OF CORN HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED WE WILL START BY
ADOPTING OUR COMMITTEE RULES
THESE RULES HAVE BEEN PROVIDED
ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR REVIEW. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL BE DOTTING THE
WE WILL ADOPT THE COMMITTEE
RULES FOR THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO
LEGISLATIVE SESSION HEARING NO
OBJECTIONS. THIS COMMITTEE THE
COMMITTEE RULES ARE ADOPTED.
MEMBERS THE PLAN FOR TODAY IS
TO BEGIN WITH OUR CONSENT ITEMS
THEN MOVING THROUGH THE AGENDA
AND FILE ORDER. THE ONLY
EXCEPTION WILL BE MY BILLS
WHICH I WILL TAKE UP AT THE END
OF THE HEARING AFTER EACH BILL
IS PRESENTED WE WILL PLACE THE
BILL ON CALL. AFTER ALL THE
BILLS HAVE BEEN HEARD I WILL
OPEN THE ROLL CALL CALL ON EACH
BILL ONCE AGAIN TO GIVE MEMBERS
WHO WERE IN IN OTHER COMMITTEES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON
TODAY'S BILLS. WILL NOW MOVE IN
TO OUR CONSENT CALENDAR THESE
ARE TWO BILLS ON CONSENT THEIR
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE. SB THREE
OH TWO FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE S.
B. FOUR NINETY FOUR. CAN I HAVE
A MOTION ON OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
CENTER WILL THANK YOU CENTER
WILK- MEMBERS PLEASE READ A
REMINDER TO PLEASE WAIT UNTIL
YOUR MY CONCERN DODD TO SPEAK
DIRECTLY TO THE MIKE- FOR THOSE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
REMINDER TO PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND BILL NUMBER BEFORE
CAST YOUR VOTE. IF YOU ARE NOT
VOTING ON A PARTICULAR MEASURE
PLEASE MAKE SURE TO STAY NOT
VOTING SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. REMEMBER THIS IS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THIS
INCLUDES FILE ITEM FIVE SB
THREE OH TWO AND FILE ITEM NINE
SB FOUR NINETY FOUR DOT. HI DON
HI NIELSEN. DIAZ NIELSEN AYE
ALLEN. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI
ARCHULETA HI BAKER. HI SENATE
RECORD HE PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND WHAT YOU'RE VOTING ON.
THE NUTCRACKER AND SO I ON THIS
MEASURE. BAKER HI GORGEOUS.
BORDERS HI BRADFORD GLAZER.
SENATOR GLAZER ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HI GLAZER HI WESO AYE
HUESO HAI JONES HI JONES HI
MELENDEZ HI MELENDEZ AYE
PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO HI RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WILK. WELCOME HI
THAT'S THIRTEEN ZERO GERMAN
POLITICAL. OKAY THAT THAT'S
THIRTEEN ZERO THIS BILL IS ON
CALL OKAY NOW LET'S HEAR FROM
OUR FIRST- AUTHOR I BELIEVE
CENTER GLAZER WILL BE
PRESENTING SB NINETEEN REMOTELY
CENTER GLAZER PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO BEGIN. THANK YOU I CHAIR
DIED IN MEMBERS SAT THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT S.
B. NINETEEN- IT'S ALL IT ALLOWS
LICENSE WINE AND BRANDY
MANUFACTURERS TO HAVE BUT TO
OFF SITE TASTING ROOMS. UNDER
EXISTING LAW WINERIES ARE ONLY
ALLOWED TO TASTING ROOMS ONE AT
THEIR PRODUCTION FACILITY AND A
SECOND OFF SITE- BUT FOR
SMALLER WINERIES THAT WAY THEY
DON'T PRODUCE THEIR WINES ON
THEIR FACILITIES IT PROVIDES AT
SIGNIFICANT DISADVANTAGE. THIS
BILL ACTUALLY CAME ABOUT
BECAUSE OF A TOUR OF MY
DISTRICT HAVE OVER SIXTY
WINERIES AND I GOT TO MEET
STEVE NEVER SU FROM STEVEN KENT
WINERY WE TALKED ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES OF HIS SMALL WINERY
HE'S GOING TO TESTIFY IN JUST A
MOMENT. HERE IS STORY OUT
FURTHER BUT IN ADDITION TO THE
SPECIFIC PROBLEMS- SMALL
WINERIES THE ENTIRE CALIFORNIA
WINE INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
CHALLENGED BY BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN LOST REVENUES
DAMAGES FROM THE COBIZ NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND WILDFIRES. SO ALL
OF CALIFORNIA WINERIES BIG AND
SMALL WOULD BENEFIT FROM THE
OPTION OPEN ONE MORE OFF SITE
TASTING ROOM. LET ME KNOW THIS
LEGISLATION AND SIMILAR FORM
WAS PASSED BY THIS COMMITTEE
UNANIMOUSLY IN THE LAST SESSION
AS WELL AS OFF THE SENATE FLOOR
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. IS TYLER
BLACK NEED FROM THE WINE
INSTITUTE AND STEPHEN MERECE SU
FROM. STEVEN KENT WINERY. BUT
THAT IS FOR SURE I RESPECTFULLY
FOR NOT VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOING. NOW WILL MOVE ON
TO- LET'S START THAT I TRY
BLACK. I REMEMBER THIS IS
BEFORE YOUR UNDERSUPPLY BEYONCE
YEAH TO THE CAN REGARDING I'D
LIKE TO HEARINGS I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS- THE COMMITTEE
CHAIR AND- I ASK THAT WE KEEP
TESTIMONY TO EITHER SIDE BY
THREE MINUTES. ALL THOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUCH LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. SO- NOW- THIS BLACK
YOU CAN SPEAK THANK YOU. YES
GOOD MORNING YOUR MEMBERS AND
I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF-
THIS IS TOLERABLE WITH THE WIND
IS. SB NINETEEN WHICH ADDICTS
WILL PROVIDE ONE RESERVE THE
OPTION ON THE SECOND
POSSIBILITIES YOUR- FOR MANY OF
THE THOUSAND OF SMALL
CALIFORNIA WINERIES FROM ST.
ROOMS ARE THE LIFEBLOOD THEIR
OPERATIONS THEY SERVE AS- THE
PRIMARY SOURCE OF CONTACT WITH
CONSUMERS THE PRIMARY ECONOMIC
DRIVER OF THEIR OPERATIONS. AND
TASTING ROOMS ENJOY A
REPUTATION AS ESTABLISHMENT OF
MODEST CONSUMPTION COMINGUP A
YEAR MARKED BY. ECONOMIC
HARDSHIPS DUKE OF THE NINETEEN
WILDFIRES NOW MORE THAN EVER-
CALIFORNIA WINERIES SELLING
UNIQUELY CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
MADE BY HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS. NEED ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO CONNECT
CALIFORNIA WHEN YOU CONSUMERS
AND WITH THAT- I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE HONESTLY NINETEEN AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. THANKS
MISTER BLACK THE. MISTER
MARISSA- FLOOR'S YOURS. GOOD
MORNING JERRY MEMBERS MY NAME'S
STEVE CAN GARRISON ON THE SIX
CHEN Y. IN CEO OF THE STEPHEN
CARE WINERY LOOK IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY IN A LIVE VALLEY AND
HERE'S OF SB NINETY. I WANNA
THINK CENTER STAFF MUCH NEEDED
SUPPORT AND PERSEVERANCE ALMOST
EIGHTY FIVE PER OF ALL ONE IN
CALIFORNIA CLASSIFIED AS SMALL
WHICH GENERALLY MAKES THEM
UNSUITABLE FOR WIDE SCALE
WHOLESALE DISTRIBUTION. I LEAST
NEED THEIR TASTING ROOMS IN
ORDER TO SURVIVE IN A VERY
COMPETITIVE BUSINESS SURVIVES
RIDERS. ANOTHER QUESTION
ENTIRELY ABOUT 75% OF MY SALES
ARE THE WINE CLUB MEMBERS AND
GENERAL PUBLIC TO VISIT MY
TASTING ROOMS. AS A ONE EIGHT
P. A SMALL ONE YOU'RE RENTING
SPACE IN A LARGER FACILITY I
ONLY HAVE ACCESS TO LEGAL
ACCESS TO ONE TASTY BUT WHICH
PUTS ME AND MINE WAS LIKE MINE
AT A LARGE COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE. ADDRESS THE
NINETEEN BUT HE EVEN THE
PLAYING FIELD AND ALLOW US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMPETE MORE
FAVORABLY WITH THE THOUSANDS
ARE THE ONES THAT HAVE MULTIPLE
TASTING ROOMS. QUALITY SEEMS
ARE GOVERNED BY STATE AND LOCAL
LAWS AND REGULATIONS BECAUSE OF
THIS AN INCREASE IN THE NUMBER
OF TASTING ROOMS WOULD BE
HANDLED RESPONSIBLY AND IN AN
ORGANIZED FASHION. BY LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES. THE SAKE OF
SOME AN OWNED MULTI.
BUSINESSES MINE I URGE YOU TO.
THAT NINETY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER MOORE-
NOW LET'S BE WITH ANY WITNESS
HERE IN THE GALLERY. SEEING
NONE- ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINETEEN. ALSO SEEING NONE.
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. NINETEEN WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE ZERO
PRESS ONE ENTER ON YOUR PHONE.
SURE WE DO HAVE PEOPLE OF
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK JUST A MOMENT PLACE.
THANK YOU MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFIED
SUPPORT WHEN YOU CAN. RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE THREE VERY GOOD. OR
READY IF YOU CAN OPEN THE LINES
AND- LET THE SUPPORT WITNESSES
TESTIFY INDIVIDUALLY WILL
CONTINUE. YES MISTER CHAIR JUST
JUST ONE MORE MOMENT PLEASE
WERE ALMOST READY. THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE
TWENTY FIVE Y. TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH I'M SORRY
I'M ACTUALLY WAITING TO POSE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO NOW GO TO
LINE TWENTY LINE TWENTY YEAR
ONE IS OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MR KAREN MEMBER STACEY
DOLLY ON BEHALF OF THE FAMILY
WINEMAKERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WE NOW GO
TO LINE TWENTY NINE. KEN LYNCH
VINTNERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU. BUT YOU
SURE THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THAT
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
COULD YOU PLEASE ASK SO WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET ALL THE
COMMENT THAT- THIS BILL
DESERVES- ONE MORE TIME PLEASE.
AND AGAIN LATEST JOB MEANT FOR
YOUR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. BUDGET SHIRT NO ONE IS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE- THERE
WERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. SEEING NONE AS WELL.
NOW WE WILL MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA. TELECONFERENCE SERVICE-
MODERATOR IF YOU'LL PLEASE PROP
THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
NINETEEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMAN TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION A PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE WILL NOW TO RETURN TO THE
ONE TWENTY FIVE BY TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU-
MISTER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MICHAEL SKIP OF REPRESENTING
ALCOHOL JUSTICE. AND THE
CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL POLICY
ALLIANCE WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THERE ARE NO ONE ELSE'S-
IS A SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK AT THIS TIME JUST. FOR
THE SAME PROCESS COULD YOU
PLEASE ASK ONE MORE TIME. AND
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
PRESS ONE ZERO. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. MISTER
CHAIR NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU OPERATOR AND
THANK YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WE WILL
NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO THE MEMBERS. DO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. WE HAVE A- I SAW HIM
FIRST FROM SENATOR GORGEOUS
SORRY- CENTER WILL. MISTER
CHAIRMAN I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE- THE CENTER FROM CONTRA
COSTA THIS IS A GOOD BILL PROUD
TO SUPPORT. WE HAVE A MOTION
ANY ANY OTHER SPEAKERS. SAYING
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION BY THE
RULING. ENTER WILL- A AND-
CENTER GLAZER DO YOU HAVE ANY
GOOD A WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
PLEASE. THANK YOU CHAIR DOT IN
THE COMMITTEE FOR HEARING THIS
BILL AND I APPRECIATE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE THE-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY- CENTER
GLAZER THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE FIRST TO BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE SB NINETEEN MOTION IS TO
PASS THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
DODD. DOT HI NIELSEN ALL RIGHT
NIELSEN HI ALAN. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA HI VENTURA HI BAKER I
SENATOR USE A STATE YOUR NAME
UP BILL YOUR PORTING ON AND
CHARGE BAKER I ON B. NINE THE
SENATE BACKERS BAKER HI. FOR
BORDERS HI BROWN. GLAZER
SENATOR GLAZERS SB NINETEEN HI
GREAT HI WESO FIVE WESO ART
JONES I JOE HI MELINDA I
MELENDEZ PORTED HI PORTANTINO
IRA. RUBIO I WILL HI. WELCOME
HI THAT'S THIRTEEN ZERO
CHAIRMAN PUT IT ON BECAUSE THAT
THE HAS VOTES WILL THE BILL ON
CALL. NUMBER MOVE MEMBERS TO-
FILE NUMBER NUMBER. SB THREE
SIX CENTER- BURKE YOU MAY BE
HERE. THANK MISTER CHAIRMAN. OF
A ONE OFF. THANK CHAIRED A STEP
WE PAY. A MONIQUE FOR THE WORK
COMMUNICATION ON THIS BILL IN
THE ON. ADVANCE THIS POLICY
FORWARD. THIS IS A SIMPLE BILL
IN A VERY COMPLICATED AREA OF
THE LAW. WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
EXPANDS THE EXEMPTION OF THE
TIED HOUSE RULE THE CURRENTLY
EXIST AT THE HONDA CENTER HONDA
CENTERS IN ORANGE COUNTY. WHERE
THE MIGHTY DUCKS PLAY. IN
EXPANDS IT TO THE SURROUNDING.
A PROPOSED DEVELOPMENT CALLED
OC FIVE THINK- LA LIVE BUT
NEWER AND COOLER. THIS IS
IMPORTANT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THE
PROJECT BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
IT'S IMPORTANT ECONOMIC.
ADVANCEMENT DEVELOPMENT OF- THE
REGION- THIS WILL PROVIDE THIS
THIS DEVELOPMENT WILL PROVIDE.
THOUSANDS OF CONSTRUCTION JOBS
AS WELL AS MANY THOUSANDS OF
JOBS ONCE IT'S OPERATIONAL-
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY. OUR
MISTER MATT HICKS THE VICE
PRESIDENT PUBLIC AFFAIRS FOR OC
VIDE SPORTS ENTERTAINMENT.
MISTER JOHN LATIMER. REPRESENTS
CLIENTS- C. FIVE SPORTS.
ENTERTAINMENT OKAY WILL BE IN
THE MISTER HICKS. THE FLORIDA.
JOINING CHAIR DIED IN MEMBER OF
THE CAN MY NAME IS MATT HICKS
ON THE V. OF PUBLIC AFFAIRS FOR
OC FIVE SPORTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT WE WANT TO THANK
CENTER GROUNDWORK FOR
SPONSORING THIS BILL AS
BACKGROUND- C. FIVE IS A NINETY
FIVE ACRE DEVELOPMENT SPONSORED
BY THE OWNERS OF THE ANAHEIM
DUCKS. WAS THE FIVE WILL BE A
MIXED USE COMMUNITY ALIGNERS
DISTRICT WHICH WILL SURROUNDING
HONDA CENTER IN ANAHEIM. THIS
BILL WILL IMPORTANTLY GENERATE
AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED
THOUSANDS OF CONSTRUCTION JOBS
AND MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND
JOBS UPON ITS OPERATION IT ALSO
FULFILLS THE VISION FOR THE
CITY OF ANAHEIM FOR THIS AREA
PROVIDING. A TRUE PLACE FOR
LIVE WORK PLAY- ALSO WANTED TO.
THAT THE PROJECT WILL GENERATE
SIGNIFICANT REVENUE. AND
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY FOR ANAHEIM
IN ORANGE COUNTY THIS IS AN
AREA THAT'S BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC.
BECAUSE OF ITS RELIANCE ON
TOURISM. AND SO WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR HEARING THIS BILL
TODAY RESPECTFULLY URGE AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU MISTER HICKS
MISALIGNMENT. MERGERS MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN LATIMER
ON BEHALF OF- SEE FIVE MINUTES
WANTED AT POINTS OF LIGHT'S HAS
PASSED NUMEROUS TIGHT HOUSE
EXEMPTIONS IN THIS AREA IN THE
PAST TYPICALLY THOSE TIGHT AUS
EXEMPTIONS HAVE BEEN RELATIVE
TO STADIUMS AND ARENAS BUT NOT
ALWAYS. BUT THOSE TITLES
EXEMPTIONS WORK PASSED FOR
STADIUMS ARENAS AND ARENAS OUT
OF THE LOVE OF SPORT BY THE
LEGISLATURE RATHER IT WAS A
RECOGNITION BY THE LEGISLATURE.
BUT THESE WERE BIG PROJECTS
THAT HAD SIGNIFICANT VALUE IN
COMMUNITIES AND THAT VALUE WAS
WORTHY OF THE START HOUSE
EXEMPTION. WE THINK THE OC BY
PROJECT MEETS THAT SAME
CRITERIA AS MATT SAID TEN
THOUSAND INSTRUCTION JOB THREE
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT. BOB
ONE ONE OTHER POINT- THE
WHOLESALERS OFTEN HAVE CONCERNS
WITH SOME OF THESE TIGHT HOUSE
EXEMPTIONS AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT- WILL BE CLEAR. THE BILL
HAS SPECIFIC LANGUAGE THAT MAKE
SURE THAT THE WHOLESALERS ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO PROVIDE ANY
FINANCIAL SUPPORT OR COST YEAR.
TO ANY ADVERTISING OR
SPONSORSHIP THAT A MANUFACTURER
ON THEIR OWN WOULD CHOOSE TO
DO. IN THIS IN THIS DEVELOPMENT
SO THEY'RE PROTECTED FROM ANY
FINANCIAL COST BUT OF COURSE
THEY WILL BENEFIT WHEN THIS
PROJECT IS DEVELOPED THE V.
THIRTY NEW LICENSES AVAILABLE.
BILL HAVE SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY AND DINING
ENTERTAINMENT SUCH A WHICH OF
COURSE WILL BENEFIT THE WHOLE
CELL FTIR AS WELL AS THE
DEVELOPMENT. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK GOODNESS A LOT OF THE-
NOW- SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
SEEING NONE. THANK YOU WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING.
TO TESTIFY VIA. TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB. THREE EIGHTY SIX. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AGAIN
LATEST JUDGMENT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE MAN THERE AT THIS
TIME PRESS. ONE ZERO. THANK YOU
MODERATOR THAT WHEN YOU'RE
READY PLEASE OPEN THE LINE TO
CALL THE SUPPORT WITNESSES
INDIVIDUALLY. MISTER CHAIR I
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE ONE PERSON
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK AT THIS
TIME WE'LL GO TO LINE HAD. GO
AHEAD SIR OR MA'AM- ED MATURE I
APOLOGIZE ONE ANALYST HAS-
DISCONNECTED FROM THE CALL WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME
LET'S TEST ONE MORE TIME
OPERATOR AND THEN WE CAN MOVE
ON IF THERE'S NOBODY. ON THE
LINE. AND AGAIN LATEST GERMAN
FOR YOUR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. BUDGET SURE THERE'S NO
ONE IN Q. THAT WISHES TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU- MODERATOR- NOW
HAVING- WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
NOW ARE THERE IS- ANY WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY IN OPPOSITION-
TO SB THREE EIGHTY SIX. SEEING
NONE ABBOTT ROOM ONE TWELVE C.
NINE OPERATOR COULD YOU CALL
WITNESSES POLICE. AGAINST IN
OPPOSITION TO THREE SB. THREE
EIGHTY SIX. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
THIS TIME. PRESS ONE AND ZERO
THIS TIME IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE AT LEAST
FOUR PEOPLE WHO ARE SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH WINE TWENTY
FIVE. PLEASE PROCEED. BY TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MICHAEL SKIPPER REPRESENTING
ALCOHOL JUSTICE WE RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU MR SKIPPER- NEXT
CALLER. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
LINE TWENTY TWO. IN A SLOW
COOKER CALIFORNIA BEER AND
BEVERAGE DISTRIBUTOR
DISTRIBUTORS WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION THE SONG. EXCEPTION
IS OVERLY BROAD AND NEEDS MORE
SPECIFICALLY- I'VE HAD SOME
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
AND HE'D COMMITTED THAT HE WAS
GOING TO WORK WITH US- I DIDN'T
HEAR IT DOES OPEN AND I'M- I'M
HOPING THAT WE'LL HEAR IT IN
HIS CLOTHES- BUT WE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE. THIRTY ONE.
YES THIS IS JOE BANG TESTIFYING
ON BEHALF OF YOUNG'S MARKET
REPUBLIC. THE PREVIOUS WITNESS
SAID WE HAVE HAD GOOD FAITH
DISCUSSIONS WITH BOTH THE
AUTHOR AND THE SUPPORTERS OF
THE BILL. THOSE GOOD FAITH
DISCUSSIONS HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS THERE. ARE
A COUPLE OF SMALLER TORN ISSUES
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON BUT- WE
EXPECT TO- HOPEFULLY HAVE FULL
AGREEMENT SO THAT AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE THIS EXEMPTION.
CONFORMS TO THOSE DONE IN THE
IN THE PAST WHILE ALSO ALLOWING
THE DEVELOPMENT TO. REALIZE THE
BENEFITS OF THE EXEMPTION IN
THIS UNIQUE CASE- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING FURTHER WITH
THE AUTHOR OR THE COMMITTEE
STAFF THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE SUPPORTERS AND REACHING. AN
AGREEMENT THERE. THANK YOU MISS
LYING THAT'S COLOR. ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD
MORNING CHAIRED MEMBERS MAKING
MOPAR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING ASSOCIATION AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION AND I WAS THE
ONLY POLICY HEARING IN THE
SENATE I UNDERSTAND THAT
GENERALLY SPEAKING THE SENATE
WOULD HEAR ISSUES RELATED TO
THE OUTDOOR ADVERTISING ACT OUT
THE PART OF THE BNP CODE AND
SENATE TRANCE COMMITTEE BUT
SINCE THE BILL WAS NOT DOUBLE
REFERRED THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE
TO RAISE THEIR CONCERNS HERE.
GENERALLY SPEAKING THE CSO A
HAVE NOT WEIGHED IN ON SITE
HOUSE EXEMPTIONS THE GIVEN THE
SIZE AND SCALE OF THIS
EXEMPTION AND THE FACT THAT THE
PROPOSED DEVELOPMENT DOES HAVE
DONE ALONG STATE ROUTE FIFTY
SEVEN IT RAISES MANY QUESTIONS
FOR OUR MEMBERS THAT THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS ENFORCED THE
OUTDOOR ADVERTISING ACTIONS
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE WITH
FEDERAL OVERSIGHT FROM THE
FEDERAL HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION-
AND RECENTLY HAD TAP ON IT
TOUGH QUESTIONS AND CITED
CALIFORNIA SIGNS. AND
PARTICULARLY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA FOR OVERSIZED WALL
SCAPE AND SO OUR MEMBERS FELT
LIKE WHEN THE LEGISLATURE IS
CONSIDERING A LARGE INVENTION
IN A DIFFERENT SECTION OF THE
MP CODE IT MIGHT BE AN
APPROPRIATE TIME TO REMIND
DEVELOPERS AS THE FEATHER
SECTION BE IN PICO TO THE
OUTDOOR ADVERTISING ACT TO
ENSURE THAT SIZE ZONING AND
SPACING REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE.
DUPLICATED BUILT IN FEDERAL AND
STATE LAW ARE MAD WE UNDERSTAND
THAT FROM CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE SPONSORS THAT THEY DON'T
BELIEVE THEY ARE SEEKING AN
EXEMPTION SO OUR HOPE IS THAT
THEY WOULD JUST BACK CONFIRM
THAT AND LANGUAGE JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T PUT CALTRANS
IN A POSITION TO BE RECEIVING
FEDERAL OVERSIGHT AND AUDIT
FROM THE FAD WHICH DOES THAT
POTENTIALLY LEAD TO ARRESTS
AGAINST TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
NOTHING FORWARD. WE HOPE TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH AUTHORS
AND SPONSORS- AND APPRECIATE
THE EXTRA TIME TO UNDERSTAND
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT ARE YOUR
COLLEAGUES IN TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE WOULD GENERALLY LOOK
AT BUT AGAIN GIVEN. THAT THIS
IS A POLICY HEARING. FOR THIS
IS. DEL IT VERY IMPORTANT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WEEK- NOW
GO TO GO TO LIE THIRTIES. HELLO
THIS PART MISTER CHAIRMAN IS
TRUE FLY REPRESENT SOUTHERN
COURT POPULATION WANTED SPEAR
HOLES. AND I WOULD LIKE TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT WE ARE SUPPORT
THE L. BY **** MR LOW IN RISK
WERE WITH THE OFFICE ON ON AND
POP SO WE ACROSS TO SPEND MOST
OF MAGIC. THANK YOU MACINNES
FLANAGAN NEXT BE. BLIND SEVEN.
MISTER CHAIRED BY THE IS CHRIS
WALKED ON OF CAL CAN'T LOOSER-
ALSO IN THE PROGRAM WASN'T.
WELL OVER THE THREE MINUTES
ALLOTTED TO EACH SIDE COULD YOU
JUST STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. SORRY YOU BET
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
INDULGENT- WE'RE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
NEXT BEAKER. SURE THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
COULD YOU PLEASE ASK ONE MORE
TIME OPERATOR. WATER HEATER FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
MILLION. PRESS ONE ANDZERO.
RESEARCHER KNOWN AS SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK OKAY
THANK YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WE WILL
NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO THE MEMBERS SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY CHANCE WE DO NOT. ANY
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK CENTER
NIELSEN. THE CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS- I HAVE A LONG HISTORY
OF DEALING WITH THESE TIED
HOUSE BILLS. AND THE HISTORY
WOULD INDICATE THAT THEY
USUALLY ALWAYS GET WORKED OUT
SOMEWHERE ANOTHER. THERE HAVE
BEEN RARE OCCASIONS WHEN THEY
HAVE BEEN CONTENTIOUS BUT NOT
VERY OFTEN. IN THE RECORD THAT
ARE. ANALYSIS SHOWS UNTIL NINE
THESE MOSTLY HAVE NOT RECEIVED
ANY OPPOSITION. AND THE AUTHOR
IS CERTAINLY A PERSON OF THE
WORD AROUND HERE COULD BE
TRUSTED. AND THAT THERE IS A
DYNAMIC FOR CONTINUED
DISCUSSIONS AS THE BILL MOVES
ALONG I HAVE A HIGH DEGREE OF
CONFIDENCE THAT THE IF IT COULD
BE WORKED OUT IT WILL BE AND
THAT WAS DISPOSED ME TO MOVE
THE BILL. HM CHEETOS COMMENTS
FROM THE DEMONS THANK YOU
CENTER- SIDEROXYLON. THANK OF
THIS YEAR I SEE THIS BILL AS A
REGIONAL ISSUE NOT JUST A
DISTRICT ISSUE OF MY DISTRICT
THE THIRTY SECOND WHICH IS-
ENCOMPASSES ONE OF PARK IN THIS
IS ANAHEIM WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF
AFFECTED BY THE PANDEMIC- THE
UNEMPLOYMENT IS BEEN SO
AFFECTED THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
THAT THAT ENTIRE REGION CAN
START LOOKING FOR A BETTER
FUTURE IN FACT IT'S EXEMPTIONS
HAPPENED I THINK IT'S A GREAT
START AND A GREAT MOVIE- AND
I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT THE
OPPOSITION IS STILL WORKING-
WITH THE SPONSOR SO I I'D LIKE
TO- ADD MY SUPPORT. TO SP THREE
EIGHTY SIX AND GO HEAD AND-
VOTE YES ON THANK YOU CENTER
ARCHULETA- THE CENTRE. ALAN THE
MOVE HERE FROM SENATOR GLAZERS.
YEAH THANK YOU FOR YOUR- MISTER.
I DATED TEN TO BE IN LINE WITH
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES
JUST NOW BUT I WILL SAY- I
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR. IF IT'S AT
ALL POSSIBLE THE THOUGHTS OF
THE FOLKS IN THE CRAFT
BREWERIES- YOU KNOW MY I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S A LOT OF
CONTROVERSY OVER THE- AND OVER
THE OUTDOOR ADVERTISING ISSUES
AND THE FEDERAL LAW AND- AND I
HAD A LONG CHAT WITH MR LATIMER
THIS MORNING GOT SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES CLARIFIED- BUT I. BUT
YOU KNOW MY PERSONAL- INTEREST
IN PROTECTING THE TIED HOUSE
LAWS REALLY HAS MORE TO DO WITH
CONSUMER CHOICE AND ENSURING
AYE I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT OUR-
OUR CRAFT BREWERY. RENAISSANCE
HERE INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA HAS
A LOT TO DO WITH A TIGHT HOUSE
RULES AND I'D LOVE TO JUST GET
A SENSE. FROM THEM AS TO WHAT
THEIR CONCERNS ARE IF THAT'S AT
ALL POSSIBLE I UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY WERE NOT- AS- YOU KNOW.
THE WANT TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS-
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO BECAUSE THE
PREVIOUS. OPPONENTS HAD SPOKEN
BUT THE PREVIOUS GROUPS. HAVE A
DIFFERENT SET OF CONCERNS WITH
THIS PARTICULAR BILL THAT I
WOULD THINK THE CROPPERS WOULD
HAVE. IT IS NOT POSSIBLE ITS
FINEST. I BELIEVE MISTER WALKER
STILL ON THE LINE. SEVERAL
APPRECIATE THAT THAT-
SUGGESTION IF MISTER WALKER. ON
THE LINE YOU TWO ARE GOING TO
GET YOUR TIME. SO WHAT WE'LL DO
SINCE IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE HE'S
ONLINE IF HE CALLS IN WE GET
DONE WITH OTHER SPEAKERS ALL
ASK THE MODERATOR ONE MORE TIME
WE'RE WAITING FOR A CALL FROM
MR CHRIS WALKER SO NOW AT THIS
POINT TIME WE'RE GOING TO TURN.
TO SENATOR GLAZERS. THANK YOU
SHARE DIED. AT FIRST I WANT TO
SAY I APPRECIATE THE
DEVELOPERS- WILLINGNESS TO
INVEST IN OUR STATE- IT'S A
BIG- DEVELOPMENT THAT HEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT HAD A CHANCE TO
TALK WITH THEM AND IT'S VERY
IMPRESSIVE AND- AND I'S A BIG
INVESTMENT AND I APPRECIATE.
THE RISKS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT. BUT THE QUESTION
THAT IS BEFORE US TODAY IS-
IT'S MUCH BROADER THAN A
STADIUM ONE OFF- AND TROUBLE
THAT IT'S- IT'S VERY BROAD IN
SCOPE AND THAT HAS MANY.
IMPLICATIONS WAY BEYOND THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT THERE ARE
OTHER- INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED AROUND OUR STATE LA
LIVE. A NUMBER OF OTHERS. WERE
YOU COULD MAKE THE SAME
RATIONALE FOR THIS EXEMPTION
FOR THOSE DEVELOPMENTS- THAT
THAT ALREADY HAD. INVESTED IN
OUR OPERATING EVEN EVEN MALL.
SO I APPRECIATE HEARING THAT
THE AUTHOR IS INTERESTED IN.
CONTINUING THOSE DISCUSSIONS-
AND THE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED ABOUT THE PRACTICE THIS.
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL. AND I KNOW
THAT I CENTER NUMBER TO BE
EXACT A MAN OF GREAT INTEGRITY
AYE. AM. NOT HEARTENED BY HIS
COMMITMENT. TO TRY TO WORK THIS
IS OUT IT'S LIKE THERE'S ENOUGH
TO MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD OUT
OF COMMITTEE TODAY I'M GOING
TO. STAY OFF ON IT AND HOPE
THAT- THAT THAT WORK IN THOSE
COMPROMISES SAID THAT NEARLY
COULD OCCUR. I WOULD HOPE THAT
I CAN SUPPORT ON THE SENATE
FLOOR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZERS
CENTER RUBIO. NO OKAY AT THE
CENTER JONES THEN SERVER MODELS.
THANK YOU CHAIR AT THE- ONE OF
THE SPEAKERS MAKE IT THERE
MIGHT CENTER POLICE. ONE OF THE
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION WAS OUR
OUTDOOR ADVERTISING ASSOCIATION
AND- IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM
IT SEEMS LIKE THERE AMENDMENT
OR THE- NEGOTIATIONS ARE ASKING
FOR PRETTY SIMPLE I WAS
WONDERING IF THE- AUTHOR OR THE
SPONSORS COULD. SPEAK TO THAT
AND- YOU KNOW LET US MAYBE GIVE
US AN UPDATE ON THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. SENATE BILL
WOULD YOU WISH TO TAKE A-
QUESTION SURE FROM CENTER
JONES- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SIR JONES
MISTER LOPER IS CORRECT THAT I
HAVE COMMITTED TO WORK WITH.
MISTER LOBORTIS CLIENTS AS WELL
AS MISTER LANG WE ALL THREE
SPOKE ABOUT THIS BILL. AND IT
IS- SOMETHING THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A WORK IN
PROGRESS CONCERNING THE OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING AT- MISS MEGAN
LOPER RAISE THE ISSUE. I I'M
I'M AWARE OF THE ISSUE- WE HAVE
NOT BEGUN CONVERSATION IT IS MY
BELIEF THAT THAT THIS BILL DOES
NOT IMPACT THE OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING ACT. BUT WILL UP
UNTIL DEAL WITH THAT ISSUE.
CENTER MELENDEZ- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THROUGH YOU IF I
COULD JUST ASK THE AUTHOR IF
HIS INTENTION IS TO- WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION AND TAKE
AMENDMENTS DOWN THE ROAD.
CINERAMA YES IT IS I MENTIONED-
I'VE SPOKEN MISTER LOPER AND
MISTER LANG AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM I
THINK WE GET THIS WORKED OUT-
AS TO A SPECIFIC AMENDMENT I'M
NOT SURE OF AT THIS POINT IN
TIME. BUT- WE WOULD ASK THAT
THE BILL MOVE FORWARD SO AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION. AS POINTED OUT BY
CENTER NIELSEN- THE MOST OF THE
TIME THESE THINGS GET WORKED
OUT AND I HAVE- CONFIDENCE THAT
THOSE THAT I'M SPEAKING WITH-
THAT WE WILL. WE WILL WORK IT
OUT. CORRECT YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
I CAN'T PREDICT THE FUTURE WITH
1100% CERTAINTY- JONES
RESEARCHER THANKS I KNOW THAT
THE- BILL'S BEEN MOVED- IN THE
MOTION. DOES IT GO WHERE DOES
IT GO I DIDN'T HEAR THAT. THAT
MOTION WHO I'M NOT. ABLE SOME.
STILL CASTS INTERNET YOU CENTER
THE MEALS AND I'M SORRY I
MISSED THAT- AS FAR AS WE GO
FROM HERE. APPROPRIATIONS
APPROPRIATIONS GREAT OKAY THANK
YOU KNOW AND I AGREE WITH THE
PREVIOUS COMMENTS THAT THE
AUTHOR IN THE AND THE-
ADVOCATES ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
ISSUE WERE. PEOPLE THAT ARE. I
THINK CAN WORK THIS THING OUT
SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST DON'T WANT TO BELABOR THE
POINT BUT I DO WANNA GO SOME OF
THE COMMENTS OF. ALL THE GREAT
SENATOR FROM FROM NORWALK ON IT
IS A NEIGHBORING DISTRICT TO
MINE AND WHEN WE HEAR JOBS.
HOUSING ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN
THE TIME THAT WE NEEDED SO
DESPERATELY ON I THINK THAT
IT'S SOMETHING WE NEED TO
EXPLORE BUT I AM REALLY
ENCOURAGED BY THE AUTHOR WHO IS
WILLING TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS AND-
CONTINUES TO DO SO AND TRY TO
COME TO A COMPROMISE SO. I WILL
ALSO MOVE HIS FELLOW AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
CONTINUE TO WORK ON ALL THE
CONCERNS THANK YOU. AFTER THE
GREAT QUOTE FROM THE CENTER OF
A NORWALK- WE WILL MOVE NOW TO-
CHRIS WALKER WHO I BELIEVE IS
ON THE LINE MISTER WALKER.
MODERATOR CAN YOU SEE IF MISTER
WALKER IS ON THE LINE PLEASE.
YES M. PARDON ME JUST A MOMENT
LET'S HAVE A LOOK HERE. MISTER
WALKER IF YOU HAD JOINED INTO
THE CONFERENCE AS A PARTICIPANT
PLEASE PRESS ONE CONCERT THIS
TIME SO THAT I CAN SEE YOUR
LINE. OKAY JUST A MOMENT. ONE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THIS IS MISTER WALKER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR SORRY FOR THE
DELAY BOB JUST TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION WHY THE CALIFORNIA
CRAFT BREWERS ASSOCIATION ARE
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED. TRIED
HEALTH LAWS ARE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT FOR OUR SURVIVAL BOB
SLOTTING FEES DO NOT APPLY TO
ALCOHOL UNDER CURRENT LAW AS WE
CONTINUE TO PIERCE THROUGH THE
TIED HOUSE LAWS WHETHER IT'S
FOR A- PUBLIC GOOD ARENA
THEATRE ETCETERA WHICH IS
TYPICALLY BEEN THAT THE CASES
WERE NOW EXTENDING IT OUT TO ME
TO USE. A RESIDENTIAL
COMMERCIAL- THAT IS THE FUTURE
OF DEVELOPMENT IN CALIFORNIA IS
TO REPAIR THE BY OUR URBAN
CORE- IF IN FACT VIDAK SECTIONS.
WILL APPLY TO MIXED USE
PROJECTS. IF THE THERE IS NO
TIME HOUSE LAW. SO WE'RE VERY
ABOUT SCOPE- IN BROUGH. OF THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. SENATE
ALLEN YEAH I THINK THAT THOSE
THOSE CONCERNS ARE AT THE HEART
OF MY CONCERN HERE IT'S YOU
KNOW I WAS GOING THROUGH ALL OF
THE- PREVIOUS BILLS MENTION THE
ANALYSIS THAT ARE RELATING TO
THIS. TOPIC AND IT SEEMS AS
THOUGH TO A T. IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN. AN EXEMPTION SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO AN ARENA OR STADIUM-
SOME LIVE. ENTERTAINMENT
FACILITY AND WHILE THIS IS
CERTAINLYTIED TO THE HONDA
CENTER. AND THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF THE SIGNIFICANT LIVE
ENTERTAINMENT ASPECTS OF THIS
PROJECT. AS WAS MENTIONED IT'S
ALSO A BROADER MIXED USE
PROJECT WITH RETAIL AND
COMMERCIAL SPACE IN. OFFICE
BUILDINGS AND MIXED INCOME ON
HOUSING IN. A NUMBER OF OTHER
THINGS SO. YOU KNOW ANYWAY AND
I HEAR THAT THIS IS THIS IS THE
WAY THE FUTURE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
MORE THESE KIND OF PROJECTS I
ACTUALLY THINK THIS IS A MUCH
MORE APPEALING PROJECT TO HAVE
AROUND THE STADIUM THAN. THAN
WE HAD IN THE PAST WHERE YOU
THROW STADIUM WAY OUT- IN IN
THE IN THE- IN THE IN THE-
PERIPHERY OF THE CITY AND PUT
IN A HUGE PARKING LOT AND LET
PEOPLE DRIVE THERE AND HAVE NO
LOCAL LIFE. I APPRECIATE THIS
KIND OF PROJECT AND APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT THIS KIND OF
PROJECT IS LARGELY FINANCED.
THROUGH MANY MANY MECHANISMS
BUT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PART
OF THE FINANCING SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT AND- I'D LIKE.
MY SENTIMENT IS TO TRY TO. GIVE
THE- AUTHORITY TO WORK ON SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED BUT I DO HAVE. I DO
I DO WANT TO JUST STATE MY
PHILOSOPHICAL CONCERN I'D LOVE
TO HEAR. AUTHOR'S THOUGHTS ON
THIS ABOUT. IT IS REALLY IS THE
WAY THE FUTURE OF FOR FUTURE
DEVELOPMENTS- YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT WHAT IS THIS WHERE WHERE
WHERE DO WE DRAW THE LINE I
MEAN DO WE THE PROJECTS HAVE TO
BE ATTACHED TO A STADIUM IN
ORDER TO. GET THIS TYPE HOUSE
EXEMPTION IN THEFUTURE. AND IS
AGAIN- OF YOU KNOW IS IT DOES
HAVE TO BE A BILL THAT'S THE
PROJECT IT'S LARGE ENOUGH TO
ATTRACT ATTENTION FROM.
SACRAMENTO INTEREST SERVICE
MEMBERS LEGISLATURE HOW HOW HOW
SHOULD WE BE. OUR THINKING
PHILOSOPHICALLY ABOUT A BILL
LIKE THIS- WHICH ISN'T IT WHICH
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE AND HIGHLY
REASONABLE IN AND OF ITSELF.
BUT I THINK THAT THE PRIMARY
CONCERN YOU'RE HEARING IS THE-
THE PRESIDENT MAY SET AND HOW
SHOULD WE THINK ABOUT THIS FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE- CENTER
OPERATIVE IF. TO CHECK.
CEREBRAL SURE- THANK YOU MISTER
AND CENTER OUT- GREAT QUESTION.
HOWEVER WE'RE WE'RE DEALING
WITH WITH ONE DEVELOPMENT ONE
PROJECT AND I SUPPOSE THAT THE
ANSWER IS THAT IS EACH PROJECT
COMES BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE WE
HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION AS TO
HOW BROAD THE EXEMPTIONS IS
GOING TO BE IN THIS CASE- IT
IS. THE ANCHOR. TEN AND SO TO
SPEAK IS THE IS THE HONDA
CENTER. AND THIS IS THE
DEVELOPMENT JUST AROUND THE
HONDA CENTER. NOW IN THE FUTURE
IF IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S GOING TO
BE MUCH MUCH BROADER THAN THIS.
WE CAN WE CAN WE CAN VOTE NOW
AT THAT POINT IN TIME. RIGHT
NOW I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY WHAT
LINE WE WITHDRAW EXCEPT TO LOOK
AT THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT AND
SAY DOES THIS MEET OUR
PHILOSOPHIC. SORT OF CRITERIA
AND ADDS TO THE CRAFT BREWERS.
ORTON IN STRING CALIFORNIA VERY
IMPORTANT IS IN CALIFORNIA WE
WANT TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY CONTINUE TO
THRIVE. OF MR LATIMER'S HERE I
THINK HE'S UPSTAIRS. IF HE HAS
ANY IDEA TO BE HAPPY TO HEAR
WHAT HE HAS TO SAY. YEAH THAT'S
A LOT OF OUR PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN- TO THE
QUESTION FROM CENTER AROUND FOR
SHE DOES WELL- CERTAINLY THIS
BILL PROVIDES AN EXEMPTION AS
AS CENTER BURKE SAID IT BUILDS
ON A CURRENT EXEMPTION. AT THE
HONDA CENTER ALREADY HAS. SO
THIS IS NOT A NEW TOOL IF YOU
WILL TO THE TO THE SAME VOTE
YOU'RE GONNA OPERATE O. C. BY
DEVELOPMENT THERE ALL THEY HAVE
HAD A- TIED HOUSE EXEMPTION AT
THE HONDA CENTER FOR MANY
YEARS. AND URBAN NO COMPLAINTS
ABOUT THE WAY ATTACHED TO THE
USE OF THAT TIME HOUSE
EXEMPTION INCLUDING FROM CRAFT
BREWERS. WHO WE SELL THEIR
PRODUCTS IN THE HONDA CENTER
AND WE CERTAINLY WOULD BE
SELLING THEIR PRODUCT. WITHIN
THE OTHER LARGER DEVELOPMENT.
THESE ARE TOOLS THAT RETAILERS
AND MANUFACTURERS USED
TOGETHER. SO I APPRECIATE THAT
EACH ONE OF THESE HAS TO BE
LOOKED AT BUT I DO DISTINCT
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE YOU STILL
COME BACK TO IN THE CASE THIS
PROJECT. WE HAVE THE HONDA
CENTER ENTERTAINMENT CENTER.
THE PROJECT HAS A SIX THOUSAND
SEAT- A CONCERT HALL IN A. TWO
THOUSAND SEAT AMPHITHEATER. ALL
LOT OF INNER TEAM IN THERE IN
THIS. WAY YOU WOULD FIND IN A-
TO. LIKE A STADIUM OR ARENA SO
AGAIN WE THINK IT MEETS THE
PREVIOUS TEST. BUT ALSO SAY TO
THE POINT OF EARLY LIFE EARLY
LIFE HAS ONE OF THESE TITLES
EXEMPTIONS AS WELL. WE ARE
STARTING TO SEE A DIFFERENT
CHANGE AND DEVELOPMENT IN EACH
ONE OF THESE WILL BE HAVE TO BE
LOOKED AT BUT AGAIN IN THE CASE
OF THIS ONE ARE OWNERS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN UTILIZING TIGHT
HOUSE EXEMPTION UTILIZING
RESPONSIBLY. AND EXPANDING IT
TO THIS DEVELOPMENT WE THINK
MAKES GOOD SENSE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SEE NO OTHER
COMMENTS- CENTER ALLEN I- I
THINK IT'S PROBABLY- BODES WELL
FOR A INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
PERHAPS ONE CLOVE IT'S OVER SO
THAT WE CAN DISCUSS AND BRING
IN. ALL THE DIFFERENT PLAYERS.
SO A LOT OF MEMBERSHERE IN
THE- SUMMER AND HOT. OBVIOUSLY
BUT- WEEKEND- YOU'LL GET THE
INFORMATION THAT WE NEED SO
THAT- AS THESE- POLICY CHANGES
ARE REQUESTED- WE HAVE MORE
INFORMATION FROM THE SITE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BRING
THAT UP. MISTER CHAIR I WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE
I DO THINK THAT WE'VE YOU KNOW
I I'VE SPOKEN TO MISTER A LOT
ABOUT THIS I MEAN THERE ARE
OTHER JURISDICTIONS OF THE
OTHER COUNTRIES WHERE. ON WHERE
WHERE THE ACCESS TO ADD TO THE
TWO PRODUCTS ARE ARE YOU KNOW
ULTIMATELY MUCH MORE RESTRICTED
YOU KNOW THAT DID YOU HAVE A
ONCE ONE BREWERY WILL BY A
CHAIN OF PUBS IN THE UK AND
THEN ALL YOU CAN BUY IS THAT
PARTICULAR. BREWERIES PRODUCT
LINE AND WE YOU KNOW WE'VE
WE'VE THIS THIS WONDERFUL
RENAISSANCE OF CRAFT BREWERY
CRAFT DISTILLERIES CENTER HAS
HAPPENED BECAUSE OF THE TIGHT
HOUSE RULES I JUST REALLY WANNA
MAKE SURE FOR YOU MAKING
CHANGES. THAT WE NOT STYMIE
THAT CREATIVITY AND GROWTH AND
WE FIGURE OUT SOME. PATH MOVING
FORWARD THAT WILL PROTECT THEM.
THANK YOU CENTER- THAT
CONCLUDES ALL DISCUSSION ON
THIS MATTER- CENTER- BURKE-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE-
THANK YOU MISTER JUST BRIEFLY
AS AN ARCH ALETTA CENTER RUBIO
POINT OUT THIS IS A REGIONAL
PROJECT- AS MR LOPER MISTER
LANG POINT OUT THIS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM ON. HI SHARES
OF BROWN'S CONCERNS WITH
RESPECT TO CRAFT BREWERIES WILL
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO WHAT WE
CAN AT LEAST TO- HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THEM TO DEAL
WITH THEIR CONCERNS- AND MISTER
CHAIR WITH OTHERS AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE FIRST- BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS FILE
ITEM SIX SB THREE EIGHTY SIX
MOTION IS TO PASS FOR FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS DOT ALL. DOT HI
NIELSEN ALL RIGHT NIELSEN HI
ALLEN. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA ON
ARCHULETA HI BAKER. THIS IS
JOSH BECKER- I ON THREE SIX
BAKER HI GORGEOUS. GORGEOUS
HIGH BRADFORD. GLAZER. THIS IS
SENATOR GLAZER ON SB THREE
EIGHTY SIX NOT VOTING AND FOR
PURPOSES OF DISCLOSURE OF HAD A
STAFF MEMBER WHO'S JUST ARRIVED
AT THE OFFICE I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT'S ON THE RECORD THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU THE NAME
GLAZER NONVOTING WESSEL. JONES
HI JONES HI MELENDEZ.
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE WILK HI
WELCOME HI. THAT'S CENTER TREAD
AS THOUGH IT'S- THE BILL WILL
BE ON CALL WILL NOW MOVE TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S. B.
FOR THIRTY CENTER BOARD ISSUE
MAYBE GET. LITTLE HOUSEKEEPING
FIRST. CONSIDER BORDERS GETTING
AWAY FOR ONE SECOND ORIGINALLY
CENTER GLAZER COULD YOU
IDENTIFY THE STAFF MEMBER THIS
IN YOUR OFFICE PLEASE. I CENTER
GLAZER- MY STAFFER CHRISTIAN
OROZCO. CHRISTIAN ROESLER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER. HE SENATE
ABORTION MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU
ARE CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL FOR THIRTY A BILL THAT
WOULD HELP SMALL BUSINESSES BY
CREATING A PROCESS BY WHICH
STATE AGENCIES CAN ESTABLISH
PROCEDURES FOR THE REDUCTION OF
CIVIL PENALTIES UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES. THIS BILL
CLOSELY RESEMBLES FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN WHICH LAST YEAR
PASSED OUT OF THE SENATE
UNANIMOUSLY BUT UNFORTUNATELY
WAS STALLED BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. ANY SMALL BUSINESSES
DO NOT HAVE THE SAME
ORGANIZATIONAL RESOURCES
AVAILABLE AS LARGER COMPANIES
DO SUCH AS HAVING LEGAL
DEPARTMENTS AND COMPLIANCE
DEPARTMENT. THIS GONNA
FORTUNATELY RESULT IN A VERY
REAL OPPORTUNITY IMBALANCE
BETWEEN LARGE CORPORATIONS. AND
SMALL MOM AND POPS TRYING TO
SURVIVE IN CALIFORNIA. MODELED
AFTER THE SMALL BUSINESS
REGULATORY ENFORCEMENT ACT
PASSED BY CONGRESS IN THE
NINETIES SB FORTY DOES NOT.
LESSEN REGULATORY STANDARDS OR
REDUCE THE RULE MAKING
AUTHORITY OF THE STATE AGENCIES
BUT INSTEAD SEEKS TO PREVENT
PENALTIES FOR MINOR INFRACTIONS
FROM LEADING TO FINANCIAL RUIN.
UNDER THIS BILL SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE REQUIRED TO MEET
CERTAIN CRITERIA TO QUALIFY FOR
PENALTY REDUCTIONS. INCLUDING
THAT THE VIOLATION DID NOT
INVOLVE WILLFUL OR CRIMINAL
CONDUCT HE DID NOT POSE A
SERIOUS HEALTH SAFETY OR
ENVIRONMENTAL THREAT. SB FOUR
THREE ALSO PROVIDES FACTORS FOR
STATE AGENCIES TO CONSIDER IF
AND TO WHAT EXTENT THE PENALTY
SHOULD BE REDUCED WHICH INCLUDE
THE DEGREE TO WHICH SMALL
BUSINESS COOPERATED DURING ANY
INVESTIGATION. ENGAGE IN
SUBSEQUENT ACTION TO CORRECT
THE VIOLATION PRIOR HISTORY OF
MEETING REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS. IF THE PENALTY
WOULD IMPEDE THE SMALL
BUSINESSES FROM CONTINUING TO
OPERATE AND IF THE ACTIONS WERE
NEGLIGENT. STATE AGENCIES WOULD
BE ARE AUTHORIZED TO APPLY
CONDITIONS TO THE REDUCTION OF
PENALTIES INCLUDING REQUIRING
THE SMALL BUSINESS TAKE
CORRECTIVE ACTION OR TEN SPOTS
SPECIFIED TRAINING. THOUSANDS
OF SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE
SHUTTERED THEIR DOORS DURING
THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
MANY MORE WILL FOLLOW. NOW MORE
THAN EVER CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
TAKE INSTITUTIONAL ACTION TO
PROVIDE REGULATORY FINANCIAL
RELIEF TO SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
ARE A VITAL PART OF OUR
COMMUNITY. RIGHT ORGANIZING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR
COMMUNITY WHILE ALSO SUPPORTING
MEASURES THAT RESPONSIBLY AND
SUSTAINABLY STRENGTHEN OUR
ECONOMY IS A RESPONSIBILITY WE
HAVE AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB.
FOUR THIRTY. THANK YOU- MISTER
BORGES'S- WE WILL NOW OR CENTER
BORDERS WE WILL NOW MOVE O TO
ANYONE- WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. CENTER BORDERS I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE DAVID BTLER
AND LAWRENCE KEATON ON THE
COASTLINE IN SUPPORT. SO WE'LL
START OFF WITH MR BUTLER. THE
CHAIRMAN DIED- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANKS SO MUCH FOR
THE TIME MY NAME IS DAVE BUTLER
AND TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF.
SB FOUR THIRTY ON BEHALF OF YOU
CAN THE UNITED CHAMBER ADVOCACY
NETWORK WHICH IS A COALITION OF
SEVEN. LOCAL CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ORGANIZATIONS IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING OVER FOUR THOUSAND
MEMBERS. WE SURVEY OUR MEMBERS
EVERY YEAR AND AMONG THEIR TOP
CONCERNS CONSISTENTLY ARE TAXES
FEES. AND REGULATIONS. MANY OF
THESE BUSINESSES DON'T HAVE AS
A SENATOR BORDERS MENTIONED
ORGANIZATIONAL RESOURCES
AVAILABLE. TO HELP THEM
NAVIGATE CALIFORNIA'S
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT. SB FOUR
THIRTY FOUR THIRTY RECOGNIZES
THE ROLE SMALL BUSINESSES PLAY
AN ECONOMY AND SEEKS TO PROVIDE
RELIEF TO SMALL BUSINESSES
STRUGGLING CONNECT NAVIGATE.
CALIFORNIA'S COMPOUND LOCATED
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT. GIVEN
OUR CURRENT ECONOMY THE
LEGISLATURE HAS A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO SIGNIFICANTLY
BENEFIT ALL SMALL BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA- MANY BUSINESSES AND
HAVE HAD TO CLOSE THEIR DOORS
AND THOSE THAT DO REMAIN OPEN
AND ARE LOOKING FOR THE STATE
TO BE A PARTNER IN THEIR
SUCCESS. THE LEGISLATURE HAS
DONE A TREMENDOUS JOB IN
ESTABLISHING SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATES AND MANY DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES ARE WITHIN THE
STATE GOVERNMENT AND SB FOUR
THIRTY- PRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PUT THOSE SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATES. TO WORK ON BEHALF OF
SMALL BUSINESS THANKS SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY WE STRONGLY
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE SB FOUR
THIRTY. THANK YOU MISS BUTLER.
PLEASE PROCEED MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS A LARGE GAIN
POLICY DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF B FOUR THIRTY I THINK BILL
THAT WILL RETAIN AND BUILD
SMALL MANUFACTURING JOBS IN THE
STATE SOMETHING THAT WILL
BECOME MORE CRITICAL IN THE
WAKE OF THE COVER NINETEENTH
ENDEMIC ON CALIFORNIA'S MORE
THAN TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
MANUFACTURING FIRMS 93% OF
WHICH ARE SMALL AND MEDIUM
SIZED. SMALL MANY FACTORS
GENERATING HIGH LEVEL OUTPUT
EMPLOYMENT GROWTH VARIOUS
REGIONAL ECONOMIES AS A CRUCIAL
MEMBER OF OUR MANUFACTURING
SUPPLY CHAIN AND MANY OF THE
STATE'S MOMMY BACK TO STEP UP
AS LEADERS BECOME PART OF THE
STATE IN THE CALL THE NINETEEN
RECOVERY RESPONSE AVERAGE ABA
PERMITTING MANY OF THE
OPERATION OF THE FACILITY TO
PRODUCE P. B. AN INTOXICATED
HELD AT STANLEY. HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS TO CONTINUE TO
KEEP EMPLOYEES SAFE IN OUR
CRIMES GOING ON LIKE MAKING THE
CHALLENGE OF MANY SMALL BIZ IN
MANY TRACTORS FACE REALLY THE
LACK OF PERSONALITY HR PROJECT
YOU'RE TO CONTINUE TO KEEP UP
WITH THE DYNAMIC REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT OF THE STATE THIS
BILL WOULD ENCOURAGE AND ASSIST
IN THE- PROACTIVE CORRECTION OF
UNOFFICIAL MISTAKES IS NOT
THREATENED HEALTH OR SAFETY
STANDARDS RATHER THAN LOOKING
AT THOSE. COMMUNITY FRAME ON
THIS BILL REALLY DOES NOT
PROVIDE COVER FOR BAD ACTORS
WOULD REALLY GET AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR SMALL MANUFACTURERS ARE
DOES NOT GIVE UP CAN RESPOND
EFFECTIVELY RESPONSIBILITY
INSTEAD OF REALLY PROVIDE A
MECHANISM TO EXAMINE MINOR
MISTAKE CAN GIVE THE
APPROPRIATELY AT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES MANY FACTORS FROM
THE HEAVY HANDED OUT BY THE
STATUTE HIGH CALLS WILL BE THE
SETTLEMENT. SECOND GIVEN THE A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS WE SEE
THIS BILL AS AN INVESTMENT FOR
THE FUTURE OF MONEY BACK TO
THEM THIS IS WELL THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AND FOR
THESE REASONS RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE SB FOUR THIRTY
THANKS THANK YOU MISTER DAYTON-
NO OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY WANT TO LOOK TO OF
ROOM. ONE TWELVE. SEEING NO ONE
IN THE ONE. MAR IF YOU'LL
PLEASE FROM INDIVIDUAL WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SOME. OF S. B.
FOUR THIRTY. THANK YOU MISTER.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF PUSHED. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ONE ZERO YOUR PHONE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. I BELIEVE WE HAVE. ONE
PERSON WHO SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK WHY NOT. TWENTY
FOUR. PERCY BY TEARING MEMBERS.
YOUR RETIREMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR THIRTY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LICENSE INVESTIGATORS FOR ALL
THE REASONS OF EXPLAINED AND
THE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
PREVIOUSLY. THANK YOU MODERATOR
CAN YOU CALL AND SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY OTHER PEOPLE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
THIRTY. AND ONCE AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. PRESS. ONE
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR NO ONE
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NOW- WE WILL- NOW
THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL TELL FALL THE
SAME PROCESS NEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY
SCENE NONE ROOM ONE TWELVE.
SEEING NONE AS WELL- THANKS-
NOW WE'LL MOVE ON WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY. VIA
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR FEW
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. YES BEFORE THIRTY
EIGHT. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO PRESS. ONE ZERO.
WE WILL GO TO LINE FORTY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS IMAGE
TIGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE BLL WELL
WE'RE DEFINITELY SYMPATHETIC TO
THE STRUGGLES WITH SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE FACING AND I
THINK THEY'RE ALL SORTS OF
DIFFERENT WAYS WE CAN EXPLORE
HELPING THEM DEAL WITH THE
STRUGGLES WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT
EATING THE PENALTIES FOR SOME
OF WHAT ARE OFTEN VERY SERIOUS
HEALTH AND SAFETY VIOLATIONS IS
THE WAY TO GO- THERE THERE ARE
TWO DIFFERENT ISSUES WITH THE
SPELL THE FIRST WOULD BE THAT-
WE DO THINK ONE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES IS ACTUALLY A PRETTY
SMALL BUSINESS AND THAT. ARE
SORRY A PRETTY LARGE BUSINESS
AND THAT AT THAT LEVEL THEY'RE
ALL SORTS OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
RESOURCES THERE TO HELP
EMPLOYERS COMPLY WITH THE LAW
AND ESPECIALLY WITH RESPECT TO
WORKER HEALTH AND SAFETY WHAT'S
IN THIS BILL KIND OF LOOKS A
LOT LIKE WHAT'S ALREADY IN
REGULATIONS RIGHT NOW AND
ACTUALLY DOES BRING ALL SORTS
OF DIFFERENT UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES TO THE ISSUE OF
WORKER HEALTH AND SAFETY WHERE.
IT LEADS TO A LOT OF LITIGATION
THAT THEN LEADS TO A LOT OF
DIFFERENT- DELAYS IN THE
PROCESS OF THAT TRANSLATE TO
EMPLOYERS BASICALLY GETTING
ALREADY MUCH SMALLER PENALTIES
THAT CREATE A MUCH WEAKER
DISINCENTIVE AGAINST A LOT OF
THE VIOLATIONS THAT HAVE
INJURED AND FRANKLY KILLED A
LOT OF WORKERS THAT. WE
UNDERSTAND IT'S TOUGH TO KEEP
IN MIND ALL THESE DIFFERENT
REGULATIONS AND WE DEFINITELY
ARE INTERESTED IN ANYWAY IT'S
TO HELP EMPLOYERS COMPLY THINGS
LIKE A CONSULTATION UNIT THE
CALLOUS OFFERS WHEREVER WE CAN
EXPAND THAT MODEL OTHER
REGULATORY AGENCIES WILL
DEFINITELY OPEN TO THOSE TYPES
OF DISCUSSIONS BUT THAT JUST.
LOWERING THE PENALTY IS JUST
KIND OF BY DEFINITION LOWERS
THE DISINCENTIVES AGAINST. THAT
KIND OF BEHAVIOR THAT DOES
EVENTUALLY PUT OUR WORKERS
HEALTH AND SAFETY AT RISK AND
TO THOSE REASONS WE URGE OUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU MR ANY
OTHER- WITNESSES. IN OPPOSITION
OPERATOR. ONE THIRTY NINE. MORE
MR MEMBERS JACQUI STAND ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER TRACING
CALIFORNIA. AND IN OPPOSITION
TO ASK OUR THIRTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU NEXT BIGGER. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE ONE PERSON WHO'S JUST
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK JUST A MOMENT PLACE. WE
WILL NOW GO TO MINE FORTY ONE.
IN ORDER TO STRUCTURE MEMBERS
CRITICIZING THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE S. B. FOUR THIRTY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CAN YOU ASK ONE
MORE TIME A MODERATE. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO PRESS.
ONE ZERO. THERE IS NO WINNING
QUEUE TO SPEAK MUCH RICHER
THANK YOU MODERATOR THANK YOU
TO OUR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WE WILL NOW BRING
THIS BACK FOR DISCUSSION. FROM
OUR MEMBERS. I DON'T SEE ANY
MICROPHONES UP AT THIS TIME.
DID ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SEEING
NONE- DO I HAVE A MOTION. WHO'S
ATKINS REMOVED A CENTER WILL
MOVES- CENTER BORDERS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE- THE COMMENTS
HE THAT- FOLKS HAVE MADE
CALLING IN BOTH IN SUPPORT. AND
OFFERING SOME CRITICISM I WOULD
LIKE TO POINT OUT SOMETHING
THAT IS IMPORTANT FOR THE
RECORD TO MEMORIALIZE- IN THE
OFFICE IN THE ONE OPPOSITION
LETTER- I THINK THERE MIGHT BE
SOME CONFUSION I'M GOING TO
QUOTE. IS ON BEHALF OF THE-
OPPONENT. THE OPPOSITION SB
FORTY IDENTIFIES THAT SB FORTY
WOULD ALLOW BUSINESSES TO EVADE
PENALTIES FOR VIOLATING HEALTH
SAFETY OR ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATIONS OR STATUTES. THAT
FLIES DIRECTLY CONTRARY TO THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL
UNFORTUNATELY- AND I'LL
IDENTIFY THE VIOLATIONS THAT
UNDER THIS BILL SMALL BUSINESS
ARE REQUIRED TO MEET CERTAIN
CRITERIA TO QUALIFY FOR PENALTY
REDUCTION. ON THE CONDITION
THAT THE VIOLATION DID NOT
INVOLVE WILL FOR CRIMINAL
CONDUCT AND DID NOT POSE A
SERIOUS HEALTH SAFETY OR
ENVIRONMENTAL THREAT SO I THINK
THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN SOME-
CONFUSION ON. THE LANGUAGE OF
THE BILL AND I'M GLAD THEY WERE
ABLE TO CLARIFY THAT HOPEFULLY
THOSE FOLKS WOULD BE ABLE TO-
COME ON BOARD TO BE SUPPORTIVE
ALL AND WITH AN EXAMPLE HERE.
THIS IS A FOR A LITTLE WHILE
BACK THERE WAS A RESTAURANT
OWNER IN VACAVILLE CALIFORNIA
BELIEVE IT WAS. AN HISPANIC
WOMAN OWNED A RESTAURANT. SHE
WAS FINED FORTY OVER FOURTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER VIOLATIONS
THAT SHE WAS UNAWARE OF AT THE
TIME. ONE OF THE VIOLATIONS IN
PARTICULAR WAS FOR THE LACK OF
A PLUG FOR AN OUTLET. THE
VIOLATION ALONE WAS BETWEEN A
THOUSAND AND TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A TWENTY FIVE CENT
FIX. IF THIS POLICY WAS IN
PLACE THE AGENCY COULD HAVE
WORK WITH THE RESTAURANT OWNER
AND GIVEN HER THE CHANCE TO
CORRECT THE VIOLATION. AND OR
EITHER REDUCE HER PENALTY.
COVERT HAS TAUGHT US A LOT OF
THINGS ONE IN PARTICULAR IS
THAT GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO BE
MORE HUMAN. WE HAVE TO MAKE
OURSELVES AVAILABLE IN AVAIL
OURSELVES OF THE VERY PURPOSE
FOR WHICH WE EXIST. AND THAT IS
TO ALLOW FOR THE FOR THE
FUNCTIONING OF OUR COMMUNITY.
AND BEING A PARTNER LOOKING
AFTER PUBLICSAFETY BUT ALSO
BEING A PARTNER TO THE
ECONOMIC. ENGINES OF OUR
ECONOMY ESPECIALLY DURING THIS
TIME COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST BY YOUR SUPPORT FOR US
BEFORE THIRTY BECAUSE THIS IS
HOW WE MAKE GOVERNMENT. MORE
HUMAN AND CAN ALLOW FOR.
CALIFORNIA TO RECOVER MORE
PROPERLY. THANK YOU THANK YOU-
CENTER GORGEOUS- THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR WILL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
MUST RE REFER. TO THE COMMITTEE
ON BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FILE ITEM SEVEN SB FOUR THIRTY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT DODD HI.
DOT HI NELSON ALL NIELSEN AYE
ALLEN. PARTULA HI ARCHULETA
BAKER. BYE SENATOR PLEASE SAY
YOUR NAME WITHOUT YOUR YOUR-
PROFESSOR BAKER I FOUR THIRTY-
BAKER I BORDERS HI FOR JUST AYE
BRADFORD. GLAZER. SENATE
SENATOR GLAZER SP FOUR THIRTY
HI GLAZER HI WHERE SOME. JONES
HI JONES I MELENDEZ AYE
MELENDEZ AYE PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO
AYE WILK HI WELL BY THE BILL
HAS ELEVEN VOTES WILL PUT IN A
CALL. GERMAN YES OR OKAY SO-
WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SP FOUR SIXTY TWO
CENTER BORDERS YOU MAYBE GET.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL FOUR SIX TWO. WHICH
WOULD ADD AT THE CREEK FIRE TO
THE LIST OF EVENTS FOR WHICH
THE STATE SHARE OF ELIGIBLE
KALLSTROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WOULD BE UP TO ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT. THE CREEK FIRE LOCATED
IN MY DISTRICT WAS THE LARGEST
SINGLE FIRE THEN IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY. BURNING
ALMOST. THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND ACRES OVER FOUR MONTHS
IN COLLEGE ON PRESIDENT DAMAGE
DURING IN ALREADY UNPRECEDENTED
TIME. THE FIRE COUPLED WITH THE
PANDEMIC HAS POSED SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES FOR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THE RESIDENTS
OF THE AREA AS THEY SEEK TO
REBUILD. I PERSONALLY VISITED
THE LOCATION OF THE FIRE
MULTIPLE TIMES IT IS CLEAR THE
DESTRUCTION CAUSED WILL BE A
SCORE IN THAT REGION FOR YEARS
TO COME. FRESNO COUNTY AND
MADERA COUNTIES ADDITIONAL
ESTIMATES PUT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SHARE OF THE COST
BETWEEN ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
AND TWO MILLION. THIS HAS DONE
THESE INCREASES IN THE PAST
PRIOR DISASTERS SUCH AS THE
EAST BAY FIRE IN THE NORTHRIDGE
EARTHQUAKE. ADDING THE CREEK
FIRE TO THE LIST OF EVENTS
WOULD BE CRUCIAL IN HELPING A
COMMUNITY HEAL. THAT IS ALSO
SUFFERING THE IMPACTS OF THE
KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR-
CENTREBOARD JUST LEAVE YOU HAVE
JOHN THOMPSON ON THE COASTLINE
IN SUPPORT. MISTER THOMPSON YOU
MAY BEGIN. GOOD MORNING CHEERED
UP MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JOHN THOMPSON AND I'M
THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR WITH THE
FRESNO COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC WORKS AND PLANNING IN
THE ACTING DIRECTOR OF RECOVERY
FOR THE REQUIRE THE NAME HAS
FIND IN SUPPORT OF THIS BEFORE
SIXTY TWO ON THE AFTER THE
COUNTY FRESNO. AT A TIME WHEN
ARGUE WITH A- THROUGH THE
ENTIRE OF THE- WEEKS. A LARGE
SINGLE SOURCE WILD STATE
HISTORY THE CREEK FARM STARTED
ON SEPTEMBER FOURTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. ON USDA LAND BURNED
ALMOST THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND ACRES. FOUR MONTHS TO
CONTAIN THE DAMAGE OR DESTROYED
AT LEAST NINE HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN STRUCTURES. IN BOTH
FRESNO MADERA COUNTY. ARE ALSO.
WE CAN. OF TREES ABOUT ROADWAYS
AND DAMAGE THE COUNTY. REGIONAL
VOICE TREATMENT PLANT. TO
PROVIDE SERVICES APPROX
FOURTEEN HUNDRED NONPROFITS.
THE RESPONSE OF THE FIRE. ARE
ALSO BECAUSE SIGNIFICANT DAMAGE
TO COUNTY MAINTAIN ROADWAYS
CULVERTS THE COUNTY ANTICIPATE
THE COSTS ARE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TO BE BETWEEN ONE HAPPENED TWO
MILLION DOLLARS AND THAT'S
BEFORE SIXTY TWO WILL HELP OUR
COMMUNITY RECUPERATE THOSE
POSH. AND WORK TO RECOVER FROM
THE DEVASTATING IMPACT OF THE
FIRE ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
FRESNO WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE. SB. FORTY FIFTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER THOMPSON THERE'S NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
WILL TURN TO ROOM ONE TWELVE.
SEEING NOBODY IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. I WILL NOW WILL. ME TOO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB. FOUR
SIX TWO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE
ONE PERSON WHO SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK LINE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSTAPPEN'S
FREEMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATIN OF
COUNTIES REPRESENTING ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SB FOUR SIXTY TWO WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE MANY
CALLS IN THE STATE'S FINANCES
HOWEVER THIS TYPE OF DISASTER
THE CLINTON OF CORN. TO
RECOVERY IN ALL THE COUNTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
HAD SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK AT THIS TIME PLEASE
REMIND MORE MORE TIME MODERATOR.
SPEAKING SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO PRESS. ONE ZERO. THERE
IS NO INDISPUTABLE SIGNALING
THAT LINK YOU MODERATOR- HAVING
HER FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WILL
NOW FALL THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION THERE
ARE NO WITNESSES AND I CAN SEE
IN THE GALLERY ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
SEEING NONE- WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
BE THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICES-
A MODERATOR YOU'RE ON. THANK
YOU ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. TWO
JOURNALISTS SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK TO REMIND THEM
ONE MORE TIME MODERATOR THAT WE
GET EQUAL TIME. AND AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE THANK YOU
MODERATOR THANKS TO ALL THOSE
WHO PARTICIPATED THIS MORNING-
DO WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS. THAT
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I
DON'T SEE ANY MAY HAVE A MOTION.
SENATOR NIELSEN MOVES FURTHER
BORDERS- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OUR
COLORS AS I MENTIONED THE
OPENING THE CREEK FIRE. WAS THE
LARGEST SINGLE FIRE EVENT IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY. LET THAT
RESONATE FOR A MOMENT THE
LAWYERS WE ARE EXPERIENCED.
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
ACRES FOUR MONTHS TO CONTAIN.
THIS BILL IS A MECHANISM BY
WHICH ARE THESE TWO COUNTIES
CAN BE OFFERED ASSISTANCE TO
COVER SOME OF THE COST IT IS
CAPPED OUT AT 75% AT THE STATE
LEVEL. IT IS ENDING COMPARISON-
THE L. A. COUNTY BUDGET THIS IS
JUST BY COMPARISON THE L. A.
COUNTY BUDGET IS ALMOST THIRTY
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS. THERE IS
BUDGET MADERA COUNTY'S BUDGET
IS A MODEST TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY MILLION. SO WHEN YOU
HAVE THE SMALL COUNTIES THAT
HAVE SUFFERED THESE
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGES I
THINK THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US. TO STEP UP AND OFFER
ASSISTANCE IN- IN AN AREA
THAT'S THE TRULY NEEDED THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU CENTER FOR
JUST- THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER NIELSEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHT
SB FOUR CITY TO MOTION IS TO
PASS THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
DODD HI. DOT HI NIELSEN. AYE
NIELSEN AYE ALLEN. ARCHULETA
AYE ARCHULETA AYE BAKER.
SKINNER BECKER. HIGH POINT FOR
SIXTY TWO BAKER HI FORGES HI
BORDERS HI BRADFORD. GLAZER.
SENATOR GLAZER SB FOUR SIXTY
TWO BY GLAZER AYE WHAT'S SO.
JONES JONES HI MELENDEZ HI
MELENDEZ HI PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO ALL RUBIO
I WOKE HI WILK HI. THAT'S
ELEVEN GERMAN IT ON CALL OKAY
THAT- WILL BE PUT UP BILL PLACE
ON CALL NOW WILL NEED TO- FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN S. B. FIVE FOUR
THREE SO- LIMóN WILL BE
PRESENTING REMOTELY. GOOD
MORNING- CEREMONY MAY BEGIN
GOOD MORNING KAREN MEMBERS I
WANTED TO START BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT.
NONPROFIT SECTOR IS THE FOURTH
LARGEST EMPLOYER IN OUR STATE
AND GENERATES ONE SIX OF
CALIFORNIANS GROSS STATE
PRODUCT AND PRODUCES OVER FORTY
BILLION INTO THE STATE EACH
YEAR FROM OUT OF STATE
RESOURCES. STATE GOVERNMENT'S
COUNT ONNON PROFITS TO PROVIDE
A RIGHT RANGE OF THE VITAL
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING 32% OF ALL MEDICARE
DESPITE THE MINOR ROLE THAT
NONPROFIT CALIFORNIA SERVICES
SUPPLY CHAIN AND ECONOMY THEY
HAVE NO DESIGNATED GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL TO HELP THEM ADDRESS
CHALLENGES IN THEIR
PARTNERSHIPS WITH STATE
AGENCIES. OR NAVIGATE AGENCY
REGULATIONS OR IMPROVE AGENCY
CONTRACT PRACTICES TO INCREASE
PROGRAM EFFECTIVENESS CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES STATE AGENCIES
THAT REGULATE OR IMPACTS SMALL
BUSINESSES TO HAVE A SMALL
BUSINESS LIAISON THERE IN.
PUBLIC FOR NONPROFIT. SB FIVE
THREE REQUIRES AGENCIES THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY REGULATOR IMPACT
NONPROFITS DESIGNATE AT LEAST
ONE PERSON AMONG EXISTING
PERSONNEL TO PERFORM THE DUTIES
OF NONPROFIT LEADS ON AND TO
ADVERTISE THE EXISTENCE OF THE
LIAISON. THE NONPROFIT LIAISON
RESPOND TO COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE
STATE AGENCY. I TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ON AGENCY REGULATION
COMPLIANCE REPORT NONPROFIT
CONCERNS TO AGENCY LEADERSHIP
AND DEVELOP INNOVATIVE
PROCUREMENT AND CONTRACTING
PRACTICES TO INCREASE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR NONPROFIT.
WHETHER IT'S HOMELESSNESS
NATURAL DISASTERS OR CURRENT
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR HAS TOUCHED
THE LIVES OF EVERY CALIFORNIA
THAT THE NONPROFIT SECTOR HAS
THE NECESSARY STATE SUPPORT TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL SERVICES TO
OUR COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A TERRIBLE
AGAIN SHOWN THE SOME OF THE
SAGA ON THE COASTLINE IN
SUPPORT- MISTER MULLIGAN. YOUR
YOUR OWN- GOOD MORNING CARE DOT
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU MY NAME
IS TERRENCE MALIK AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF NAPA
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AS
A FOUNDATION WE MADE THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS GRANTS FOR
LOCAL NONPROFITS NAPA COUNTY
LAST YEAR EVEN STILL WE WERE
THE MINORITY INVESTOR IN THE
LOCAL FACTOR BECAUSE MOST
NONPROFITS GETS MOST OF THEIR
MONEY IN THE FORM OF STATE AND
OTHER GOVERNMENTAL CONTRACTS
AND GRANTS. WHICH TYPICALLY
ACCOUNT 450% TO TWO THIRDS OF
THEIR REVENUE IN SUPPORT OF
THEIR MISSION EACH YEAR BECAUSE
OF MY JOB I TALK TO NONPROFIT
EVERYDAY SO I KNOW HOW THEY
STRUGGLE TO NAVIGATE THEIR AND
THEIR INTERACTIONS THE STATE
AGENCIES REGARDING PROGRAM
COMPLIANCE CONTRACTING. WE ALL
KNOW NONPROFIT TO PROVIDE VITAL
SERVICES YEAR ROUND BUT
PARTICULARLY IN TIMES OF
DISASTERS THEY STEP INTO THE
BREACH TIME AND AGAIN THE
SECOND RESPONDERS. SB FIVE
THREE HELP YOU MAXIMIZE
EFFICIENCY AND IMPACT OF
NONPROFITS WORKING WITH STATE
GOVERNMENT AND DISASTERS AND AT
ALL TIMES AND I RESPECTFULLY
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIGAN. NEXT
BIGGER MISTER MISS MOSS VALE
CAUGHT I HOPE I DIDN'T. GET IT
OUT TODAY THAT'S FINE IT'S AT
YOU KNOW MY DAD ALWAYS SAID YOU
KNOW DOESN'T MATTER HOW YOU SAY
IT FELT RIGHT ON THE TRACKS
HOUSING MINISTERS HERE. ARE
WRITING CHECKS HOW ABOUT- SONG.
YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD. OKAY
STAND CRACK- AND MORNING HERE
I'M CAMERA OKAY HE O. OF THE
CALIFORNIA SO OF NON. CALDERON
PROF FOR SURE WE ARE THINK
ONLINE MORE THAN THOUSAND ON
CROSS WORKING. AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATE SHOWING LONG FOR
INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT
BILL. YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE
HAS RECOGNIZED THAT GOVERNMENT
HAS AN INTEREST IN MAKING IT
EASY FOR SMALL BUSINESSES TO
CONNECT THE STATE AGENCIES. AND
THE NURTURING THE SMALL
BUSINESS SECTOR SB FIVE FORTY
THREE RECOGNIZED THAT THE STATE
HAD THE SIMILAR INTEREST IN
SUPPORTING NONPROFITS IS A
CRITICAL PART OF SUPPLY CHAIN.
SERVICES IN OUR STATE
CALIFORNIA'S ECOSYSTEM OF
SERVICES RELY ON CLOSE
INTERDEPENDENCE BETWEEN STATE
AGENCIES AND NONPROFIT IN AREAS
SUCH AS SERVICES TO PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES MEDI CAL ADDICTION
SUPPORT AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
ANIMAL WELFARE RECREATION ARTS
AND MOST RECENTLY AND VISIBLY
ESOTERIC MENTIONED COPING
NINETEEN RESPONSE OF ALL KINDS.
THIS BILL RECOGNIZES BOTH THE
IMPORTANCE AND THE UNIQUENESS A
CALIFORNIA'S NONPROFIT AND WE
ARE VERY PLEASED TO URGE FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. SUPPORTED
YOURSELF. THANK YOU MISS CUTS
I'D THAT AND NOW WE WILL. I
HAVE FOR ANY OTHER STE. IN THE-
CAL OUR IN C. NINE IN SEEING
NONE IN A ROW ONE. WILL NOW ASK
MODERATE TO. WHO WITNESSES WHAT
TO TEST IN SUPPORT VIA OF S. B.
FIVE FORTY THREE. THANK RICH
CHAIR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR KNOWING THE SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK YES ONE MORE
TIME PLEASE. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO.
THERE IS NO WINNING QUEUE THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MODERATOR-
WE'RE GOING TO DO THE SAME
THING THAT WE DID- FOR THE US
SUPPORT TO ANY WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY SEEING NONE. SEEING
NONE IN ROOM. ONE TWELVE. WE
SHOULD TESTIFIED MODERATOR WILL
CLOSE CALLING WITNESSES
WAITING. TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. IN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION SKEWS ME.
THANK YOU. AND AGAIN LATEST
GERMAN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AND IF
THERE'S NO ONE PLEASE ASK AGAIN
THANK YOU. BUT AT THE FINAL
CALL IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS THE BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO MR
CHERNOBYL THE SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'RE GONNA- BRING THIS
BACK TO OUR MEMBERS WHO HAVE
QUESTION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- SEEING AND NONE- OUR
SERVER ON THE MOMENT YOU LIKE
CLOSE. THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I HAVE A VERY VERY
GOOD MAY HAVE A MOTION. CENTER
ARCHULETA MOVES- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THIS IS
FILE ITEM TEN SB FIVE FORTY
THREE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS DOT ALL DOT HI
NELSON ALL RIGHT NIELSEN HI
ALAN. ARCHULETA HI ARCHULETA HI
BAKER. BORCHERS BORDERS HI
BRADFORD GLAZER. SENATOR GLAZER
SB FIVE FOUR THREE HI GLAZER HI
WESSEL. HI WHAT'S SO I'D JONES
I JONES HI MELENDEZ HI MELENDEZ
AYE PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE WILK
ALL RIGHT WELCOME NINE. THAT'S
ELEVEN ZERO CHAIRMAN COLIN ZERO
THEY'LL PLACE THE BILL PLACE ON
CALL NOW WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN SB FIVE FOUR
THREE CENTER HUESO YOU MAY
BEGIN. WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PERCENT. SB SEVEN TWENTY ONE
THIS IS A BILL THAT WOULD
DESIGNATE AUGUST NINTH. HAS
CALIFORNIA FARMWORKER DAY TO
HONOR. THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE BY FARMWORKERS
IN THE STATE. OF CALIFORNIA HAS
THE NUMBER ONE. LARGEST
AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY. IN THE
NATION VERY LITTLE HAS BEEN
DONE. TO RECOGNIZE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF FIVE FARMERS
MAKE. IN SUCCESS OF THIS
AMAZING INDUSTRY. OF COURSE-
THROUGH THE SCOPE OF THE CRISIS
WE ALSO LEARNED. THAT
FARMWORKERS WERE THE HARDEST
HIT. IN TERMS OF HOW. THE
PANDEMIC HAS DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED CERTAIN MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES OF THE UNITED
STATES HAS THREE MILLION FARM
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA IS KNOWN
TO HAVE THE LARGEST PROPORTION
OF FARM WORKERS. IN THIS
COUNTRY. AND ACCORDING TO THE
U. S. LABOR BUT THE U. S.
BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS
AGRICULTURE IS CONSIDERED ONE
OF THE MOST DANGEROUS
COMMON INJURIES INVOLVE
EXPOSURE TO THE ELEMENTS.
RELATED SYMPTOMS RELATED TO
PESTICIDE EXPOSURE IN BOTH
FARMWORKERS AND THEIR CHILDREN
AND FARM EQUIPMENT INJURIES I
REPRESENT- SENDING ONE PERSON
COUNTIES TO DISTRICT SERVER
FARM FAMOUS FOR FARMING
SPECIALLY PER IL. BUT WE KNOW
THAT IMPERIAL HAS SOME OF THE
HOTTEST TEMPERATURES IN THE
STATE AND MANY CASES UP TO A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE DEGREES
SUBURBAN RECORDED. IN SOME
PARTS OF MY DISTRICT AND OFTEN
TIMES WE HAVE FARMWORKERS
LABORING IN THESE VERY EXTREME
CONDITIONS THAT OFTEN GO FROM
VERY HOT TO VERY COLD. VERY
HUMID. AND I'VE HAD A CHANCE TO
EVEN ENGAGE IN SOME FORM
WORKING MYSELF FOR MY LIFE AND
WORKING ALONGSIDE FARMWORKERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND I HAVE
FOUND THEM. TO BE EXTREMELY
SKILLED WORKERS HI I CONSIDER
MYSELF A PRETTY A ABLE BODIED
PERSON BUT I JUST CAN'T SEEM TO
KEEP UP WITH THE WORKLOAD. BUT
A LOT ARE ARE VERY SKILLED
FARMWORKERS DO AND IT'S GOOD
IT'S VERY AWE INSPIRING. BANKER
IT'S ALL OF YOU TO. MAKE A TRIP
OUT TO THE FARM AND- AND TRY TO
KEEP UP WITH THE WORKERS OUT
THERE THAT ARE JUST SO AMAZING
IN TERMS OF. THE LABOR THAT
THEY ARE PROVIDE. TO THIS
INDUSTRY. SO YOU KNOW I. THIS
BILL WOULD BASICALLY ESTABLISH
AUGUST NINTH OF CALIFORNIA
FARMWORKER DAY SO WE CAN
CONTINUE THESE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT- INDIAN INEQUITIES IN OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
WELL RECOGNIZING THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF FARMWORKERS
PROVIDE CALIFORNIA EVERY SINGLE
DAY AND I ASK EVERYONE SUPPORT
FOR THE WORKERS MEASURE. THANK
YOU- CENTER HUESO I UNDERSTAND
YOU HAVE A GREAT MARCO CESAR
LIZARRAGA WAITING TO- THE
TESTIFYING. IS AN INTERLOCAL
MICHAEL THE SECOND AS EARLY
SOUTHERN GUYS ON THE LINE AND
YOU REPRESENTS LIKE MICHAEL
CAMPESINA OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU EVEN LIKE MY PRONUNCIATION.
IT WAS FINE. IT WAS JUST WRONG.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS STUFF UP
OKAY- THE FLOOR'S YOURS SIR.
OKAY AND MY AND MY VERY. WHAT
ARE YOU KNOW I RECALL MANY
THINGS BEFORE I WOULD MY LAST
NIGHT. SO AGAIN MY NAME IS SAM
AUDIBLE AND I HERE TO RESTORE
LOCAL BE OKAY. AND I'M HERE TO
TEST IN SUPPORT OF THEIR LEASE
EVERY TWO ONE COULD THERE'S A
ABA NINE YEAH CAL FARMWORKERS.
IN ORDER TO HONOR ALL THE TIME.
OF ONE WORK PROVIDE PRIVILEGED.
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES CRUCIAL
UNDERSTAND HOW PEOPLE ARE
ADEQUATE. SECTOR IS TO THE
ECONOMY. FORTY THREE IN ORDER
BILLION IN A- PRODUCTS. IT MORE
THAN PEOPLE OF THE STATES AND
THE CALL ABOUT FARM HAD BACK.
THREE GET THE SKILLED LABOR
COUNTRY'S TO TRUST CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL ALL. GOALS ON. THE
CALL WATER AND LIMITED CALLED
DEFINING MOMENT THEM NOW. OF
THE SENSHI. OF THE FARMWORKERS.
LEGAL STORM WE A- THEIR THE
NEXT NAY TO THE DAY FIRE OR TO
PREACH. THEY WILL DECKED IT
ALONG WITH THE TO FUND
PROVIDING A. INTERESTINGLY THE
ACT. INDUSTRY EQUITIES WE SEE
CAL. FARMWORKERS WHETHER IT BE-
WAGE. GRAYSON COLLEGE TO HAVE
ON THE JOB OR RATE OF COLBY. HI
HOW FAR WORKERS. SB SEVEN
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBER AND CHAIR. THANK YOU MR
LEE SAID I GOT- NOW- GONNA LOOK
AT THE KEY IT'S NOBODY ALL. A
ROOM ONE TWELVE NOBODY THERE.
ARE ANY WITNESSES WAITING TO
THE TELL A SERVICE MODERATOR
COULD YOU PRODUCT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING. TO- IN SUPPORT IT SO.
TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN OUR AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK AND OF THE
BILL PRESS ZERO BECAUSE TIME.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE AT LEAST
ONE PERSONOR TWO PEOPLE WHO
CHEWED UP SIGNALING THEY WISH
TO SPEAK JUST A MOMENT PLACE.
THANK YOU.
PARDON ME FOR THE
DELAY IN THIS CHURCH JUST A
MOMENT.
IN JUST A MOMENT LONGER
MATURE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. WELL NOW HEAR FROM
LINE. TWENTY SIX. GOOD MORNING-
CAN HEARING. YEAH LINE IS OPEN
YES THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING-
THIS IS BRIAN LITTLE WITH
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION I AM- CALLING TO
INTENSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I AM HERE TO EXPRESS
A SUPPORTERS AMENDED POSITION
ON SB SEVEN TWENTY ONE- WE- ARE
SUPPORTED OF THE IDEA OF
CREATING A CALIFORNIA FARM
WORKERS DAY- WE RECOGNIZE THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE THAT. HOLD
WORKFORCE. FOR EVER IN FOR
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND SMALL FARM
OPERATORS A CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU REPRESENTS. OUR CONCERNS
WITH THE FIGHTING SECTION IN
THE LEGISLATION- WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT SOME OF THOSE
FINDINGS FAILED TO RECOGNIZE
THE- EFFORTS THAT CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL PLAYERS MAKE TO TRY TO
PROTECT. THEIR EMPLOYEES HAVE
BEEN SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WILL
CONTINUE TO MAKE GOING FORWARD
AND THE HERCULEAN EFFORTS ARE
MAKING EVEN NOW TO TRY TO
PROVIDE ACCESS. AND EVEN
ORGANIZING WORKSITE TAXATION
EVENTS FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES- SO
WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT AMENDED
POSITION AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU MISSILE
NEXT BECAUSE POLICE. WHY.
THIRTY EIGHT. WHY THIRTY EIGHT
ALAINA OPEN. GOING TO MOVE ON
THE LINE. FORTY TWO. ONE FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
FORTY TWO TO ONE IS OPEN PLEASE
RESPOND. MISTER CHERUB
APPARENTLY WE HAD ISSUES WITH
THOSE ADDITIONAL LINE NUMBERS
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK WE GET
GOING TO INVITE THE PLEASE
THANK YOU THE PUBLIC. IF YOU IF
YOU DO WISH TO SPEAK. PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO. WE'RE
GOING TO ATTEMPT TO REACH LINE
FORTY TWO AGAIN. MY FORTY TWO
YEAR LINES OPEN. PARDON ME JUST
A MOMENT. PARDON ME MISTER
CHAIRMAN TO TRY THIS- A THIRD
TIME HERE- IF YOU DO NOT WISH
TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. EACH YEAR
WE HAVE NO WE NEED TO WITH THIS
TIME PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS NOW WILL FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION OPERATOR CAN CALL.
OPPOSITION WITNESSES TO SB.
SEVEN TWENTY ONE. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND. ZERO AS CHAIR NO
ONE THE SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK ON THEIR OWN FIVE ONE
FINAL TIME HERE FINAL PAUL. FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN. ZERO THIS YEAR THERE IS
NO ONE SIGNALED THAT THEY WERE
TO SPEAK. I THANK YOU- MODERN
MADHUR- NOW WHAT WE'LL DO- COME
BACK TO- MEMBERS QUESTIONS A
COMMON US DEALS YOUR FOR. YES
UNDER THIS TERM ANNEX THIS IS A
OF A HOST OCCASION. WE HAVE.
FOR AND IN THE WHO FORMALLY
HAVE NOT ON THE SAME SIDE OF
THINGS. ALL IN SUPPORT OF THE-
A PARTICULARLY NO THESE ARE
TWO. THE LORD FOR TO LEARN
YOUNG WHO THE FILIPINO
FARMWORKERS. AND THE FARM
BUREAU. S. I THINK THAT'S A
VERY SPECIAL AND NON IN THAT OF
THE VALUE OF THE FARMWORKERS.
I'M QUITE FAMILIAR WITH THE
COOPERATIVE INCOME SINA- MISTER
WAS A GOOD FOR OF MINE AND I
WERE WITH THIS. FOR SOME.
THIRTY FORTY. TODAY A
PROTECTING THEIR THAN HOW IN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF FIRST
TIME I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS UP MEASURE
FORWARD I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO RECOGNIZE
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
FARMWORKERS. AS A PROUD
DAUGHTER OF AN IMMIGRANT
FARMWORKER- I KNOW THE STORIES
ALL TO WELL THE LONG DAYS THE
EXTREME HEAT THE BACK ACHES.
AND JUST SHEER EXHAUSTION AND
SO FARMWORKERS ARE THE BACKBONE.
OF YOU KNOW OF THE INDUSTRY
PUTTING FOOD ON OUR TABLES AND
I THINK IT'S LONG OVERDUE THAT
WE RECOGNIZE SOME FOR WHAT THEY
ARE ESSENTIAL. TO THIS COUNTRY.
MY FATHER CAME OVER TO THIS
COUNTRY WITH AN OPEN INVITATION
TO JOIN THEM BUT I SETTLE
PROGRAM. BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THE WORKFORCE. AND TYPICALLY
FROM MARKETS TO THE JOBS THAT
MOST PEOPLE WOULDN'T EVEN
CONSIDER. AND SO AGAIN I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
MEASURE IN ITS- OVERDUE THAT WE
RECOGNIZE HOW IMPORTANT
FARMWORKERS ARE. TO ALL OF US
WITH THAT I ALSO URGE AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER BORDERS. I MISTER FIVE I
WANT TO THANK MY FRIEND FROM
SAN DIEGO. I MEAN THIS IS
HUGELY IMPORTANT AND- I'M
NORMALLY NOT THE TYPE OF PERSON
TO GLOAT. BUT I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU KNOW BUT FRESNO COUNTY IS
THE- HI THIS PRODUCING QUALITY
AND ALL OF CALIFORNIA IN TERMS
OF AGRICULTURE HAS WERE THROW
THAT OUT THERE FOR YOU. BECAUSE
I WANT TO THANK YOU BRING THIS
MORE TIED- PRE AGRICOLE IS NOT
JUST A- THE- IT IS TO INDUSTRY.
AND TO OUR WAY OF LIFE. IT'S
ALSO NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE I
THINK IT'S FUNDAMENTAL THAT WE
THAT WE BEGIN LOOKING AT IT IN
THAT WAY AND APPLYING THE
IMPORTANCE IT DESERVES- GOING
BACK A COUPLE OF MINISTRATIONS-
THE PRESIDENT AND THE MINISTER
AND- THE EXECUTIVE OFFICIALS.
OPERATED FOOD WATER SECURITY
INTERNATIONAL SECURITY PLATFORM
SO AS WETALK ABOUT THIS AND IN
ORDER THE FARMWORKERS. AND- THE
FOLKS THAT ARE PART OF THE
ENTIRE APPARATUS FROM
DISTRIBUTION TO PROCESSING-
EVEN TO OWNERSHIP- THERE'S AN
ENTIRE NETWORK OF THE CENTRAL
WORKERS AND I'M GLAD YOU BRING
THIS FORWARD TO HIGHLIGHT THIS
ESPECIALLY AS COVERT AS
HIGHLIGHTED SOME OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL NATIONAL SECURITY
WEAKNESSES. THAT WE HAVE AN
AMERICAN INFRASTRUCTURE THANK
YOU. SEVERAL CHIRLA. THANK YOU
MEASURE AND TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO- THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD SB SEVEN
TWENTY ONE OBVIOUSLY IS
OVERDUE- I THINK ALL OF US KNOW
THIS PANDEMIC IS HERE TO SOLVE
CROSS THE ENTIRE STATE BUT GETS
COUNTY AFTER COUNTY CITY AFTER
CITY WE HAVE SEEN FOOD BANKS
AND MORE FOOD BANKS AND
CONTINUOUS FOOD BANKS EVEN THIS
WEEKEND FOOD BANKS AND MORE
FOOD BANKS AND WHERE DOES IT
COME FROM BECAUSE THEY COME
FROM OUR FARMS- WHETHER IT BE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY WHETHER IT BE
FRESNO COUNTY. IT IS COMING
FROM OUR STATE AND IT IS THE
FARMWORKERS SELVES THAT HAS
KEPT THIS ENGINE GOING TO FEED
THOSE WHO NEED AND- TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THEM AUGUST NINTH
FROM THE STATE FORWARD HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
QUITE AN HONOR BECAUSE WE HAVE
A HISTORY OF RECOGNIZING THOSE
WHO SERVE REPRESENT BUT WE
DON'T STOP TO THINK HOW WE FEED
EVERYONE WHO SERVES AND
REPRESENTS THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THROUGH THE
NATION CALIFORNIA PROVIDES THE
FOOD. AND I THINK IT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY BUT IT WILL OPEN
THE DOOR FOR THE FUTURE SO WE
CAN LOOK AT THE ENVIRONMENT THE
FARM WORKERS ARE WORKING AND
THE CONDITIONS ARE AND- AND
ALSO TO MAKE SURE THAT WE TAKE
CARE OF THOSE WHO TAKE CARE OF
US IS THE WEAKEST KEPT SAYING
THE GOVERNOR SAID IT TIME AND
TIME AGAIN WE'RE IN THIS
TOGETHER SO WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THOSE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS- WHO ARE DOING THEIR
JOB FOR US. SO I GRADUALLY-
SENATOR SB SEVEN TWENTY ONE AND
I WILL ALSO LIKE TO BE A CO
AUTHOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE AND-
I LOOKED FORWARD TO SEE THIS GO
ON AND LET'S CONTINUE TO HONOR
THOSE WHO HAVE A PROVIDED THE
FOOD FOR US OVER THE YEARS
AUGUST NINTH THE MISTAKE FOR
WILL BE A DAY OF- HONORING THE
FARMWORKERS. THANK YOU SEVERAL
OF THIS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
I WANTED THE ON FOR BRING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND IT IS
CERTAINLY LONG OVERDUE. AND
THAT WE RECOGNIZE OUR
FARMWORKERS AND WE ARE VERY
VERY BLESSED. TO LIVE IN THE
STATE OF PRODUCES SO MUCH FOOD
TO FEED SO MANY PEOPLE. AND WE
DO HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF HARD WORK
BLOOD SWEAT AND TEARS THAT GOES
INTO MAKING SURE THAT THAT
FOOD. MAKES IT TO MARKET AND
GET ON THE TABLES OF
CALIFORNIANS AND THOSE ACROSS
THE NATION- MY DISTRICT.
ENCOMPASSES COACHELLA VALLEY
WHICH- AS MOST OF YOU IN HERE
NOW HAS- A LOT OF FARMWORKERS
OURSELVES IN A LOT OF
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS THAT WE
PUT OUT. ON TO CALIFORNIA
TABLES AND- I JUST AM GRATEFUL
THAT OTHER SENATORS BROUGHT
THIS BILL FORWARD SO WE CAN
PROPERLY RECOGNIZE THEM AND I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR MELENDEZ. CENTER
JONES QUESTION AND I WOULD LIKE
TO ALSO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
JUST WONDER HOW YOU THAT WHAT
WHAT SIGNIFICANT AUGUST NINTH
THAT WAS THE DATE THAT WAS
PICKED. THEY MIGHT LOCATE
GENERALLY WE PICK THE DATE THAT
WASN'T ASSOCIATED WITH ANOTHER
DAY TO SUCCEED WITH FARMERS
BECAUSE WE THINK. A LOT OF
THOSE EVENTS IN ANOTHER CELLS
DESERVE. RECOGNITION ON THEIR
OWN WE JUST SELECTED AUGUST
SIMPLY BECAUSE- IT IS GENERALLY
OF A MONTH THAT IS VERY FULL OF.
HARVESTING VOTE OF FARM WORK
AND- AND IT'S ALSO VERY HOT
MONTH AND NORMALLY DURING THESE
MONTHS- WE HAVE HAD LOTS OF
INCIDENTS RELATED TO EXPOSURE
TO THE ELEMENTS AND I JUST
THINK IT'S A MONTH WHERE. THAT
WOULD ALLOW FOR- SOME LEVEL OF.
YOU KNOW CELEBRATION. THAT
THESE WORKERS ARE OUT THERE
PART INTERPRETAR ECONOMY WOULD
ALSO. A TIME FOR US TO
CONSIDER- THE YOU KNOW THE-
OFTENTIMES WORK ENVIRONMENT
THEY HAVE TO. TOTAL THROUGH
TWO. CENTRIFUGAL CONTRIBUTION
THANKS THE SENATE JONES I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT. CONSULTING
YOUR SCHEDULE OR BEFORE THIS- I
WAS SCHEDULED. THAT IS. WITH
THAT GUY WOULD LIKE TO GO OTHER
THAN YOU THE YOU- THIS IS.
UNUSUAL BECAUSE I. AT THIS
POINT ASK. A CENTER WAYS TO.
BUT I THINK. SOME THE LIKES OF-
TO SUPPORT THAT YEAH AND ALL
THE SHE IS THE FOR THE FOR
WORKER IN THE FORMER. OVER THE-
APPARENTLY A ON THE LAW NOW MY
WORK THAT. YOU KNOW I JUST.
OPERATOR COULD YOU SEE IF MISS
WORK THE DOORS WORK THAT IS ON
THE LINE PLEASE. YES MR CHERRY
JUST A MOMENT PLEASE. THIS
WORKS- IF YOU ARE ON THE
CONFERENCE CALL RIGHT NOW
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO SIGNAL
YOUR PHONE LINES PLEASE PRESS.
ONE ZERO. AND I BELIEVE THAT WE
MAY HAVE HER LINE IS BLANK
FORTY TWO. HI A DIVORCE I THINK
YOU'RE ON NOW AT THE UNIVERSITY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GIVE ME A-
AND I GUESS WANT TO THANK WENT
ON OF THE COMMITTEE. OF THE FOR
THE CONSIDERING THE EXPECTED
LEGISLATION AND I AM HAPPY TO
SEE THAT THERE IS A PREVIOUSLY
SAID THAT WE HAVE A- ANYBODY IS
ON BOARD WITH THIS IS. AND
SOMEBODY ELSE THANK YOU LONG
WILL REDUCE. ESPECIALLY I DON'T
WANT TO BUT NOW WE HAVE TO LOOK
FOR USUALLY AND BEING
CONSIDERED. A THE NATIONAL. AND
WHEN WE COME ABOUT FORMER.
OTHER YOU'RE NOT GIFT OF THE
BOMB GET TO IT DOCTOR. AND WE
ARE VERY TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE FOR INCLUDING
FARMWORKERS FROM THERE. BECAUSE
OF THE GIVEN. AND IF THAT IF.
LATEST THE WORKERS FOR. MICHAEL
BECAME A GREAT AND SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE APPRECIATE
THAT. YOU CAN A LOOK BACK I TO
HAVE A FOLLOW GREAT DAY I THAT
IN MANY AREAS A MANY OF THE
ALREADY DO THIS PARTICULARLY TO
HAVE THIS IDEA BE UNDER STATE
LAW IT MADE SOMEDAY WE CAN A
FINANCE LEVEL THE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. YEAH THANK YOU MISS
WHERE THE. SO FOR THE FOR WORD
BEFORE THE NOW. CENTER
PORTANTINO POLK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND CHIEF INDULGE I
RISE SINCE OF- S. SEVEN ONE
SINCE THE LARGE FORTY WHICH
JUST ON A I GUESS WANT TO CAN
HER THAT IN THE C. OF BERMAN
THEY JUST TO SCHOOL THE DIVORCE
OR THE MIDDLE IN THE CITY OF TO
HUNDRED CONGRATULATED THAT FOR
THE HONOR AND IT TIES INTO HOW.
SB SEVEN ONE IS AN IRIS WELL
DONE SO THANK YOU SIR WHERE
WHICH I TO CLOSE. THANK YOU-
MISSOURI. AND I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE MEN. FOR THE NAMES TO
THIS. RESOLUTION AS EARLY AS
NINETEEN BECAUSE TWO THOUSAND-
I MEAN. TWENTY SEVENTEEN. YOU
KNOW I LEARNED THAT. NOT A
SINGLE- STATE FAIR HOWEVER
POSTED ANY KIND OF RECOGNITION.
FOR TRIBUTE OR ANYTHING OR AT
ALL TO RELATED TO. FARMWORKERS
AND- AS THE CHAIR OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS ORGANIZED THE FIRST-
EXHIBITION AND RECOGNITION AT
THE STATE FAIR. AND WITH THE
HOPE THAT THIS WOULD- TAKE ROOT
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE MORE
PEOPLE TAKE THE TIME TO
RECOGNIZE THE CONTRIBUTION OF
FARMWORKERS. MY FATHER MY
GRANDFATHER AND I I'M SURE MANY
OF YOU COULD NAME LOTS OF
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT WERE
FARMWORKERS AT ONE TIME I HAD A
GRANDFATHER THAT WAS ACTUALLY
STRUCK BY LIGHTNING TWICE. OUT
THERE IN THE IN THE FIELDS AND
HE SURVIVED BOTH INCIDENTS AND
I WAS CALLED MY GRANDFATHER THE
STRONGEST MAN IN THE WORLD. AND
OF COURSE HE CAME FROM- YOU
KNOW FORM FOR FARM WORK INTO
STOCK AND- THAT OF COURSE IS
SOMETHING THAT- WE HAVE A
TREMENDOUS PRIDE IS FAMILY AND
KNOWING WHERE WHERE I FAMILIES
COME FROM. AND I THINK IT'S
TIME AS A STATE WE TAKE- MORE
EFFORTS TO RECOGNIZE THE
CONTRIBUTION OF THE SPARTAN
SECTOR OF OUR OF OUR SOCIETY.
AND WITH THE HOPE THAT THEIR-
YOU KNOW LIVES WORKING
CONDITIONS INCOME AND
EVERYTHING THAT WE HOPE FOR
EVERYONE- SAY. WOULD CATCH UP.
AND THEY COULD- CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE IN THIS WORKING OFFER.
OF LOTS OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THEIR FAMILIES SO. THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS- AND I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE TODAY. TO APPROVE THE
BILL. SB SEVEN TWENTY ONE THANK
YOU CENTER JOHNSON JONES MAKES
THE MOTION- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE FLOOR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS FILE
ITEM ELEVEN SB SEVEN TWENTY ONE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR
DON HI DOT ALL RIGHT NIELSEN
ALL NIELSEN AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA AYE ARCHULETA AYE
BAKER. GORGEOUS ALL RIGHT
BORDERS AYE BRADFORD. GLAZER.
SENATOR GLAZERS SB SEVEN TWENTY
ONE AYE GLAZER AYE WESO AYE
HUESO AYE JONES HI JONES BY
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AYE
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
RUBIO. RUBIO I WOKE UP WELCOME
NINE ELEVEN ZERO CHAIRMAN ON
CALL- THAT GOT ELEVEN VOTES AND
WILL HOLD OUT HOPE FOR THE
ROLE- I WILL NOW PRESENT MY
THREE BILLS VICE CHAIRMAN
NIELSEN WILL NOW PER- PRESIDE
FROM HIS DESK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER NIELSEN. THE THAT.
OKAY SHALL WE PROCEED AND-
MISTER CHAIRMAN DO YOU WANT TO
TAKE UP THE COMMITTEE BILL OF
OR WHICH WOULD NOT START WITH
IT'S OKAY WITH YOU THAT- THIS
PROVIDES TERROR- SB FIFTY TWO
YES SIR. MISTER MEMBERS S. B.
FIFTY TWO WITHOUT CLARITY. THAT
PER THE PROVISIONS OF THE
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT APPLIED
TO T. ENERGIES H. IN THE BEDS.
ALSO KNOWN AS A P. S. P. S.
WITH INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY
ALERTS LOCAL GOVERNMENT. THAT A
DEGENERATION EVENT IS IMMINENT.
BOTH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ACTIVATE
THEIR EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTER TO COORDINATE ACTIVITIES
TO PROTECT HEALTH AND SAFETY IN
THE COMMUNITY WHILE THE P. S.
P. S. AS IN FACT- THE
ACTIVATION OF LOCAL EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS CENTERS INCURS.
SIGNIFICANT COSTS FOR EXAMPLE
SANTA ROSA IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN SPENT UP APPROXIMATELY
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
MARIN COUNTY OCCURRED EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR BILL. IN OCTOBER OF TWO
NINE THOUSAND NINETEEN IT'S
SOLANO COUNTY APPROXIMATELY.
ONE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
IN COSTS THE CITY OF SAN JOSE
OVER A MILLION YOU GET THE
PICTURE. THE EMERGENCY SERVICES
ACT SPECIFIES THAT IS
APPLICABLE TO CONDITIONS
RESULTING FROM A SUDDEN. AND
SEVERE ENERGY SHORTAGE IT. IS
UNCLEAR HOWEVER. WHETHER THAT
WOULD INCLUDE A DNR STATION
EVENT WHICH ADVANCE NOTICE
UNDER THAT CIRCUMSTANCE A LOCAL
JURISDICTION MAY BE ABLE TO
RECOUP ITS COSTS THE DISASTER
ASSISTANCE. SB FIFTY TWO SIMPLY
CLARIFIES THE TERM SUDDEN AND
SEVERE ENERGY SHORTAGE HAS USED
IN THE ESA INCLUDING INDIA
ENERGY STATION A VET THE BILL
SUPPORTED BY- MANY COUNTIES IN
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE- R.
C. R. C. DISABILITY RIGHTS.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES IN NAPA
COUNTY JUST THE OTHER DAY I
BECAME AWARE OF CONCERNS RAISED
BY SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC I
WILL DISCUSS AS T. GENIES
SUGGESTIONS AND SEE IF THEY CAN
BE ACCOMMODATED AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD. NOW THE
SUPERVISOR ALFREDO PEDROZA IN
R. C. R. C. ADVOCATE JOHN
KENNEDY ON THE LINE TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THEN WE WOULD HAVE. MR OF THE
DAUGHTER OF. A IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN HIS TESTIMONY IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL. GOOD
MORNING MR VICE CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS PLANES OPERATED BECAUSE
I'M SURE THE NAPA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY. ON BEHALF OF ANOTHER
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
RESPONSIBLE SB FIFTY TWO WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORT AND WOULD LIKE
TO THANK CENTER DR SALINAS UPON
THIS ISSUE. SB THIRTY TWO WILL
CLARIFY THAT THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF ARE INCLUDED IN
THE EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT.
PERSON BACKGROUND SINCE OCTOBER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AFTER CAN
EXPERIENCE THIRTEEN TSPSC BY P.
JEANNIE ONE OF THE HIGHEST IN
THE STATE. DURING THE OCTOBER
TWENTY NINETEEN PS PS IN
DEFENSE THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
METERS APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
THOUSAND RESIDENTS JUST FOR
PERSPECTIVE THAT'S ROUGHLY
SEVENTY ONE PERCENT. OF NAPA
COUNTY RESIDENTS WERE IMPACTED
BY THE PSC. ACCORDING TO
ESTIMATES UNANTICIPATED COSTS
NOT TO COUNTY ASSOCIATED WITH
JUST ONE P. SBS FROM OCTOBER
EVENTS ONE HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS. WELL THE
INTENT OF THE PSP EFFORTS TO
LIMIT THE THREAT OF WILDFIRES
DURING SPECIFIC WEATHER
CONDITIONS. TRADERS ARE THESE
EVENTS TRIGGER MANY ACTIVITIES
REQUIRED BY LOCAL AGENCIES TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH THE
FIFTY. THE DURATION OF THE
THESE ACTIVITIES INCLUDES. OUR
MOST AND- YOU LOOK JUST TWO
YEARS OF MEDICAL DEVICES.
ACCORDING THROUGH THE LOCAL
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER
WHICH ARE VERY. OPERATE CURRENT
LAW ALLOWS LOCALLY TO RECOVER
SOME OF THESE THE EMERGENCY
COVERED AND YES. CURRENTLY HAS
IT IS UNCLEAR IF THAT. OF THE
EMERGENCY OP. CENTER CALLED. U.
S. B. F. NELSON COVERED THE- SB
UNPREDICTABLE MAY IT CLEAR. FOR
THOSE REASONS THAT WE CAN START
SPONSORED FIVE TWO. THANKS DOT
AGAIN PRINTER THIS MUCH.
INTERESTING. THANK YOU SEE
BECAUSE I WE WOULD HAVE ALSO
THE SHOOT. JOHN CAN. ALSO
NUMBER. YEAH THANK YOU MY NAME
IS KENNEDY HERE TO SUPPORT SB
FIFTY TWO ON THE OF THE COUNTY
REPRESENT OF CALIFORNIA GARCIA
WITH THAT OF SEVEN WORLD. AND
THEY ACCEPTABLE SHARE BECAUSE I
CAN WILDFIRE OVER THE PST
DECADE AND EXPERIENCE MOST OF
THE STATE PSG ABOUT SOME OF
THOSE HARDEST HIT IN BUTTE
MEMBERS NOW IN ABOUT PLUME
SHASTA CHAPTERS IN ON AND HIM A
COUNTY WELL THE NUMBER OF RED
WHO COMMUNITIES AND BY TO THEM
JUST SHORT FROM OVER TO MILLION
AND TWENTY. LAUGHTER YES YES
THEN STILL HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS POPCORN WITHOUT
ELECTRICITY FOR EXTENDED OF
TIME WE SUPPORT AT THE FIFTY
TWO AS AN IMPORTANT
CLARIFICATION YEAH YES OF AND
ALL FIVE OF THEM FOR WHICH
LOCAL EMERGENCY CAN BE DECLARED
UNDER PSA YOU KNOW SEVERAL
LOCAL GOVERNMENT DECLARED LOCAL
PIZZA YES MERGING PLEASE OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS INCLUDING
MENDOCINO MONTEREY NEVADA SANTA
CLARA. AND SONOMA COUNTIES. WE
THE QUALIFICATION HELPFUL AS
NOW COUNTY'S. TO PROVIDE FOR.
TO H. TO. YES YES AND
ESPECIALLY TO SEE FINANCIAL
SYSTEMS FROM THE STATE UNDER
THE- DISASTERS. BY TO RECOVER
COSTS SAYS YOU WITH THOSE.
LOCAL OFTEN THAT LIMITED
RESOURCES YEAH YES. REALLY IN
SIGNIFICANT UNEXPECTED COSTS.
BECAUSE OF LABOUR OVERTIME
CHECK ON THAT A SOMETHING
PRESIDENT RETURN BACKUP GENO
SINCE FORTH. WE SUPPORT SB TWO
THE COMMON CLICK. TO INTERNAL
HAVE FLEXIBLE. NEED INTEREST
THE PS PS OFFENSE AND RECOVER
THOSE COSTS. AND IF YOU'LL- BY
AWKWARD FOR MOMENT AT ALSO
LARGER ARTICULATED. FOR SENATOR
BORDERS. AS BEFORE TWO THAT
ALSO UP OVER WHERE THERE'S MORE.
THANK YOU FOR AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING SUPPORT THIS
PHONE. THANK YOU. FOR CANDIDATE
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR AND-
SUPPORT. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER.
TESTING IN LINE NOW ON THE LINE.
MODERATOR. ANY SUPPORT
TESTIMONY ON THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE ENTER A
PRESS ONE IF YOU WISH TO SIGNAL
YOUR SUPPORT. AND WE WILL NOW
MAKE A FINAL CALL FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. BUT YOU CARE NO ONE
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU THEN WE WILL
THEN GO TO ROOM ONE ONE TWO TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY. ON THEIR-
APPARENTLY NOT. AND DO WE HAVE
ANYONE THE GALLERY I SEE NO ONE
IN THE GALLERY. DO WE HAVE ANY
MORE NO MORE ON THE IN THE- IN
THE QUEUE PHIL. LET US GO TO
ANY OPPOSITION THAT WOULD BE IN
THE QUEUE. ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ENTER AT THIS TIME.
THE FUTURE WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE
PERSON WHO SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME JUST
A MOMENT PLACE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JUST ANOTHER MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR. WE WILL NOW GO TO LINE
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY CHEN MEMBERS
EAGERLY NOT AN UNDERSTANDING OF
GAS AND ELECTRIC WE ARE NOT IN
OPPOSITION BUT APPRECIATE THAT-
UNDER DODD WHO'S GOING TO WORK
WITH US ON A JOURNEY AND
CONCERNS ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ACCESS DENIED
AFTER SPENDING HOWEVER AND-
THAT THE ISSUE THAT WE ARE
DISCUSSING WITH THE OFFICE UP
THERE NEEDED TO AN EPA
ESTIMATED AFTER ACTION AND SO-
JUST AGAIN APPRECIATE. THE THE
AUTHOR'S WILLINGNESS TO SPEAK
WITH US AND- LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM. THANK YOU.
OUR THANK YOU DO WE DALY BOB.
IN Q. THIRTY. OPPOSITION TO. OR
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
RICHARD AND AGAIN ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
WE WILL NOW MAKE A LAST CALL
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR NO ONE IS
SIGNALED IF THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NONE. ANYONE IN
ONE TWELVE. NOT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LOOKS LIKE WE'VE HEARD
FROM ALL SUPPORT AND ALL
OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE ANY
RETURN TO THE COMMITTEE. DO WE
HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT WISH TO COMMENT
OR TESTIFY CENTERS JONES. THANK
RESERVE CHAIRMAN I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS REGARDING ESTY
GENIE IN- THANK YOU. BURGER
INDEED A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
AND SENATOR DODD WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. WITH THE- DO
HAVE. CENTER ARCHULETA PLEASE-
THE BILL. AT THE AND THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BUT OFTEN THIS IS FILE ITEM TWO
SB FIFTY TWO MOTION IS TO PASS
THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS DOT.
START HI NIELSEN HI NIELSEN AYE
ALLEN. ARCHULETA HI ARCHULETA
I'D BAKER. BORDERS ARE BORDERS
HI BRADFORD HI BRADFORD AYE
GLAZER. SENATOR GLAZERS. SB
FIFTY TWO BY SENATE LASER CAN
YOU REPEAT THAT THE VIDEO WAS
NOT ON OUR SIDE I COULD SEE
COULD TELL SENATOR GLAZER SB
FIFTY TWO HI GLAZER HI WESSEL
HI HUESO AYE JONES HI JONES HI
MELENDEZ HI MELENDEZ I
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
RUBIO. WILK HI WELL I 11-3
GERMAN THAT THOSE ON CALL.
BILLS ON CALL- NOW WE WOULD GO
TO THE S. B. ONE OH NINE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IN SENATORS SB
ONE ON NINE WOULD ESTABLISH THE
OFFICE OF WILDFIRE TECHNOLOGY
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT WITH
IN THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES THE ESCALATING
FREQUENCY AND DEVASTATION
CAUSED BY WILDFIRES DEMANDS
THAT WE SEEK EMERGENCY INTO
EMERGING TECHNOLOGY TO ADDRESS
THIS URGENT THREAT. THIS BILL
WILL HELP DEVELOP ADVANCEMENTS
IN TAP INNOVATION FROM THE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTORS
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL REQUIRES
A NEW OFFICE THE SERVICE A
CENTRAL ORGANIZING HUB FOR THE
STATE'S IDENTIFICATION OF
EMERGENCY WILDFIRE TECHNOLOGIES
THIS BILL ALLOWS TO WORK
SMARTER. TO PROTECT LIFE AND
PROPERTY I HAVE BEEN IT WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENSURE THE OFFICES DESIGN THE
BEST MEET THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND. THIS THEY'LL
GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REQUEST THE MODERATOR TO PUT
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE WHO WOULD
BE WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IF YOU DO NOT WISH
TO SPEAK IN REGARDS TO THIS
BILL. I WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
OPEN YOUR LINE FOR PREVIOUS
BILLS DISCUSSED. AGAIN LATEST
JAVA PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. I
BELIEVE WE HAD SOMEONE FROM
LINE THIRTY TO SPEAK WITH
REGARD TO THIS BILL PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE THIRTY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES PLEASE SUPPORT SB ONE
OH NINE MY NAME IS KATHERINE
AGREEMENTS AND WE WOULD-
SUPPORT THAT ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE- FIBER. TECHNOLOGY RESEARCH
AND DEVELOPMENT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES ARE COUNTING ON THE
FIRST FRONT LINE DEALING WITH
AND RESPONDING TO INCREASINGLY
DEVASTATING CLIMATE SHERMAN
MAGNIFIERS FAMILY SUPPORT
EFFORTS TO INCREASE THE STATE
RESILIENCE AGAINST DISASTERS.
BUT AS RECENTLY. SUPPORT SB ONE
ON NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OTHER Q. THERE WAS NO ONE L.
TWO Q.WITH REGARD TO THIS BILL
MISTER CHAIRMAN I THANK YOU THE
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION. AND AGAIN IF ANYONE
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. WE
WILL NOW MAKE A FINAL CALL FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. MISTER
CHAIR BELIEVE WE HAVE ONE
PERSON TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK JUST A MOMENT PLACE.
WE WILL NOW GO TO LIVE FORTY
FOUR. PLEASE PERCENT. HI WITH
THE CALIFORNIA AND THE PACIFIC
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DOES
THAT ACT THE EXHAUST OUR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. MODERATOR.
YES MISTER CHAIR BUT THAT'S AND
DO YOU HAVE ANY OPPOSITION.
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THE FINAL CALL
FOR ANYONE WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. SURE THERE'S NO ONE WHO
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK AND I DO NOT SEE ANYONE
IN THE GALLERY AND ONE TWELVE
DO WE HAVE AN NO ONE AND ONE
TWELFTH. THAT SAID THEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN HOW. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ON YOUR VERY IMPORTANT
BILL. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE OKAY DO WE HAVE A WE
HAVE A MOTION TO. THE CENTER
BOARD OF BUSINESS VENTURES YES
I WILL CERTAINLY MAKE THE
MOTION IF I MAY ALL THESE-
TWENTY THANK- CENTER FROM NAPA.
NORMALLY NOT A BIG FAN OF
ADDING MORE DIVISIONS OF- THE
GOVERNMENT. BUT IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE. THIS IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED A MAN JUST
EARLIER PRESENTED A BILL ON THE
CREEK FIRE. THE LARGEST IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY HE TALKED TO
THE FOLKS. WHO UNDERSTAND- FIRE
DYNAMICS. THERE'S NO SUCH THING
AS A FIRE SEASON ANYMORE IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S- AN ANNUAL AND-
AROUND THE YEAR SO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. OKAY
THANK YOU WITH THAT THIS WATCH
I MEAN AT THE END JUST MAKE A
QUICK STATEMENT I'M SORRY BUT
THAT. REALLY LENT ITSELF WELL
TO THESE COMMENTS. IT I KNOW
THAT THOSE OF YOU THAT ARE IN
FIERY ARIES YOU GET CALLS ALL
THE TIME FROM. NEW TECHNOLOGIES
OR WANT TO TALK TO YOU AND SHOW
YOU WHAT'S AVAILABLE ON THE
MARKET. FRANKLY THAT'S NOT OUR
JOB TO REALLY THAT TECHNOLOGY
CERTAINLY TO HELP SOMEBODY A
POINT IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THIS WILL BE A PLACE WE CAN
POINT HIM IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION INSTEAD OF
POTENTIALLY POINTING THEM INTO
A BLACK HOLE WHICH IS FRANKLY
WHAT I'VE SEEN OVER THE- LAST
FIVE YEARS HERE IN. SACRAMENTO
SO I'M REALLY LOOKING FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU ON
THIS BILL. AND SENATOR JOHN TO
DO WHICH IS TAKE. OF OKAY NOT
THAT AGAINST ANYBODY. LET ME
NOTE ON THIS OF MY OWN READING
OF THE BILL IT IS GOING TO BE
CENTER HEADQUARTERED AT THE L.
E. . AND THERE MIGHT BE
SPECULATION OF DUPLICITY AT IT
IS THAT THAT IS NOT THE THAT
DOES NOT DUPLICATE ANYTHING
THAT THE- I WOULD SAY THAT- YES
DOES IT WOULD ENHANCE VERY MUCH
AND FOCUS ON THIS VERY CRITICAL
AREA THAT IS BECOMING MORE
CRITICAL. DO YOU HAVE A MOTION
THE. LARGEST DID PASS.
TECHNICOLOR WILL. FIRELIGHT
THREE SB OR NINE MOTION IS TO
PASS FOR FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS
DODD HI START I NIELSEN HI
NIELSEN HI ALLEN. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA AYE ARCHULETA AYE
BAKER. GORGEOUS WELL IT BORDERS
I. ALL RIGHT BRADFORD AYE
GLAZER. SENATOR GLAZER S. B.
ONE OH NINE HI GLAZER NINE WEST
SO I WAS SO I'D JONES HI JONES
HI MELENDEZ AYE MELENDEZ AYE
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
RUBIO STE WILK HI. WILL CRY
THAT'S OF THEIR ON COURT TERMS
TO THE PLAYSET BILL ON. CALL
NEXT IF THIS DIED WOULD LIKE TO
UP AS B. TWO NINE EIGHT. YES
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBER I WOULD
LIKE BEGIN BY EXCEPT ALL THE
AMENDMENTS LISTED ON THE
ANALYSIS WHICH I REALLY BELIEVE
IMPROVE THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL. S. B. NINE TWO NINE EIGHT
ALLOWS THE OWNER OF A BREWPUB
RESTAURANT LICENSE ALSO KNOWN
AS A TYPE SEVENTY FIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXCHANGE THAT
LICENSE FOR ALCOHOL RESTAURANT
LICENSE OR TYPE FORTY SEVEN
LICENSE. AS MOST OF YOU ARE
AWARE OF THE BREW PUB
RESTAURANT LICENSE ALLOWS THE
LICENSEES THE ABILITY TO
OPERATE A RESTAURANT IT ALSO
REQUIRES LICENSEE TO BROUGH A
MINIMUM OF A HUNDRED BARRELS
PER YEAR APPEAR. SOME BELIEVE
THAT MANY ORDERS A BREWPUB
RESTAURANT LICENSES ARE SIMPLY
BRING THE MINIMUM AMOUNT OF
BEER IN ORDER TO ESTABLISH A
RESTAURANT LICENSE. THIS IS
PROVED TO BE CONFUSING AND
FRUSTRATING THE LICENSE HOLDERS
I HAVE WITNESSED FIRST HAND IN
MY OWN DISTRICT. BECAUSE OF
LACK OF RESTAURANT LICENSES AT
NAPA COUNTY AND OTHER AREAS A
NUMBER OF RESTAURANT OWNERS
HAVE OTAINED. A BREWPUB
RESTAURANT LICENSE IN ORDER TO
BE ABLE TO OPEN UP A RESTAURANT
WHILE THEY'RE IN FULL
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE LAW. THE
HUNDRED BARREL BREWING
REQUIREMENT HAS NONETHELESS
CREATED FRUSTRATION FOR
EVERYBODY INVOLVED. INCLUDING
REALLY CRAFT BREW MAKERS- THE
PERHAPS DON'T THINK THAT THE
QUALITY OF FEES BRUISER
PARTICULARLY GOOD- IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SENATOR
BRADFORD'S AT S. B. TWELVE
EIGHTY THREE. INSURED THAT A
HOLDER OF A BREWPUB RESTAURANT
LICENSE WOULD NOT USE THIS
LICENSE SIMPLY OPEN TO OPEN UP
A RESTAURANT WITHOUT. HAVING AN
INTEREST IN BREWING BEER. AT
FORTY THEY'RE A NUMBER OF
LICENSES THAT OBTAINED THEIR
LICENSE PRIOR TO THE CHANGES
MADE BY S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY
THREE THAT HAVE NO INTEREST IN
BREWING BEER. AND ARE SIMPLY
FOR FILLING THAT REQUIREMENT IN
ORDER TO REMAIN COMPLIANT WITH
STATE LAW. IT'S MY STRONG
BELIEF THAT HAVING THESE
LICENSES OPERATE UNDER A
BREWPUB RESTAURANT LICENSE
RATHER THAN ALCOHOL RESTAURANT
LICENSE MAKES LITTLE SENSE. NOT
ONLY ARE THESE LICENSES
REQUIRED TO WASTE VALUABLE TIME
AND RESOURCES IN BREWERY BEER
THEY HAVE LITTLE INTEREST IN
BREWING. BUT THE DEPARTMENT ABC
IS WASTING VALUABLE RESOURCES
ENSURING THAT THEY MAY- THAT
THEY'RE KEEPING IN COMPLIANCE
WITH STATE LAW. MY BILL SB TWO
NINE EIGHT WOULD ALLOW THESE
LICENSES THE ABILITY TO
EXCHANGE OUR LICENSE FOR
ALCOHOL RESTAURANT LICENSE THIS
CHANGE MIRRORS A PROVISION IN
STATE LAW WHICH ALLOWS
LICENSEES OF AN ALCOHOL
RESTAURANT. LICENSE TO EXCHANGE
OUR LICENSE FOR A BAR. A LICE'S
AND VICE VERSA THE AMENDMENTS
ACCEPTED TODAY AMONG OTHER
THINGS REQUIRE THESE LICENSES
TO PAY THE SAME AMOUNT FOR NOW
CALL RESTAURANT LICENSES ANY
OTHER APPLICANT. THE MINUTE
ALSO PROHIBITS HE'S LICENSE
FROM BEING SOLD FOR PROFIT ON
THE OPEN MARKET. I BELIEVE THIS
BILL AS A FAIR COMPROMISE IT
ALLOWS BUSINESSES WHO HAVE
INVESTED HEAVILY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THE ABILITY TO
FINALLY OPERATE UNDER THE
APPROPRIATE LICENSE WHILE ALSO
ENSURING THAT THEY DO NOT
PROFIT FROM THE SALE OF THEIR
ALCOHOL RESTAURANT LICENSE IN
THE FUTURE. IT I THRIVE OF. I'D
THANK YOU. AND DO WE HAVE ANY
OF THE TO THE AMENDMENTS THE
AUTHOR ACCEPTS THAT AUTHORED
AMENDMENTS NOT THERE THERE WILL
BE THEN ADOPTED DO WE HAVE ANY
SUPPORT HERE IN Q. TO THE
MODERATOR. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK AT THIS TIME. OR PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO. RIGHT NOW
MOVES FINAL CALL PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR NO ONE IS SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. DO WE HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE ONE PERSON WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK. FIVE TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GLAD
LINE TWENTY FIVE SHARE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MICHAEL SKIP OF
REPRESENTING UP ALL JUSTICE-
BASED ON THE SIX AMENDMENTS
ALCOHOL JUSTICE WILL REMOVE ITS
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THAT SAID THEN.
THURMOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO GIVE
US A CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL IN. WE HAVE A MOTION. AND
A BILL BEFORE US. WITH THE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
HONESTLY TO NINETY TWO. FILE
ITEM FOR SB TWO NINETY EIGHT
THE NINE OKAY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
DODD. HI DOT HI NELSON HIGH
NELSON HI ALAN HI ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI WHAT SHOULD I
BAKER. BORDERS BORDERS I
BRADFORD ALL RIGHT HI GLAZER.
GLAZER S. B. TO NINETY EIGHT HI
GLAZER HI WESSEL ALL RIGHT
WE'RE SORRY JONES ALL RIGHT
JONES MELENDEZ HI MELENDEZ AYE
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
RUBIO. WILK HI WILK I TELL ZERO
GERMAN ON CALL. BLONDIE
COMMITTEE BILL. THAT NOW
THRILLED TO. I THINK WE'VE DONE
THAT. ALL OF THEM OKAY THOSE ON
THE CONSENT WASN'T IT YEAH YES
I WAS ON THE CONSENT OKAY GOOD
I THOUGHT WE HAD SB FOUR NINETY
FOUR CENTER DOT. THAT CONSENT
ALSO. YES OKAY THAT SAID THEN
WE THANK YOU VERY UCH CENTER
NIELSEN LET'S LET THE CALLS AND
THEN AND THEN WE CAN RUN OUT A
SO MEMBERS WILL NOW OPEN THE
PAROLE FOR EVERY BILL WE WILL
BEGIN TO DO THIS ONLY ONE TIME
SO PLEASE PAY ATTENTION SO THAT
WE CAN- CLOSE FOR THE DAY. WILL
BEGIN WITH THE CONSECUTIVE. WE
NEED CENTER RUBIO. RIGHT. WELL
IT CAN WE CAN WE START WITH AND
THEN THE NEXT BILL THEN LET'S
PROCEED AT YOUR- LET'S LET'S
LET'S DO THAT- SO WILL- FILE
NUMBER ONE S. B. NINETEEN BY
CENTER GLAZER. PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE. YOU ARE DIFFERENT THAN
CALENDAR FIRST BUT SAID CONSENT
CALENDAR. SURE LET'S TO THE
CONSECUTIVE FIRST SORRY
MEMBERS. CAN VIEW THE
CONSECUTIVE- A MOVER. SO IT IS
NOT A CONTENT CALENDAR- THIS
INCLUDES FILE ITEM FIVE SB
THREE OH TWO FILE ITEM NINE SB
FOUR NINETY FOUR- ABSENT
MEMBERS RAFFERTY JUST. THIS IS
THE CAN OF TO GO DOWN THE RULES
ALL THE VOTE BRADFORD
EVISCERATES DID YOU VOTE I SAID
BRADFORD AYE. YOUR MIND A
LITTLE- NUMBERS. REALLY THE
OKAY THERE WE GO AGAIN SAID
REFERENCE LITTLE ADDED TO
TODAY'S YOU'LL BE OKAY I CAN
BECOME I BECAUSE THE RESTAURANT
THE BEST. THE NUMBER BRADFORD
BRAD I BRADFORD AYE THAT IS
FORTY ZERO IS A GERMAN. SORRY
OKAY WE'LL MOVE THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER SB NINE HI THIS IS FILE
ITEM NE SB NINE APPS NUMBER
PROPER. BRADFORD HI BRADFORD HI
THAT'S FORTY THREE. ZERO WELL
WELL DONE. FILE IN THE TWO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO THIS IS S. B.
FIFTY TWO ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN HI BAKER. RUBIO SHE
TERMINUS DOES EARLY WANNA. ON
CALL. IT IS- THE CENTER RUBIO
GONE FOR THE NEXT SET OF BILLS
TO. HERB HER FOLDERS HERE. YEAH
THAT MEANS. PRODUKTER SHE'S
BEEN TAXES SHE SAID SHE WAS ON
HER WAY DOWN HERE. SUCH A
MEASURE WOULD BE LET'S PUT THAT
ON CALL. YEAH PUT IT ON HERE GO.
THE CHAIRS ABOLISHING CENTER
RUBY TO SCAN. YES. OKAY GREAT
LET'S START- WHERE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO START FILE ITEM TWO
FILE ITEM TO LET'S PROCEED
PERFECTED HIS FILE ITEM TWO SB
FIFTY TWO ABSENT MEMBERS BAKER.
RUBIO HI RUBIO AYE CHAIRMAN
THAT'S THIRTEEN ZERO YOU CAN
CLOSE IT IS THIRTEEN AYE AYES
ZERO NOTES THIS BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE THIS IS
FILE ITEM THREE B. ONE OH NINE
DODD. HI I'M SORRY NO ABSENT
MEMBERS BAKER. RUBIO HI RUBIO
AYE THAT'S ZERO. THIRTEEN I Z.
NAYS UP TO OUT. VIOLENT FILE
NUMBER FOUR FILE ITEM FOR IT SB
TWO NINETY EIGHT ABSENT MEMBERS
BAKER. RUBIO ALL RUBIO HI
THAT'S THIRTEEN ZERO TERM
THIRTEEN ZERO- GOT BILLS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX THIS IS
OUR MEMBERS IS FILE ITEM SIX SB
THREE EIGHTY SIX BY- CENTER ON
BERG ABSENT MEMBERS BRADFORD.
HI BRADFORD HI WESO ALL RIGHT
HUESO HI MELENDEZ. THAT IS
TWELVE TWO ZERO CHAIRMAN OF
THOSE OUT CALL BY ZERO KNOWS
THE BILL'S OUT. FOLLOWING THE
SEVEN THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVEN
SB FOUR THIRTY ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN HI ALLEN HI BRADFORD. HI
BRADFORD HI WATSON ALL RIGHT
HUESO I IS FOR ZERO ABOUT OUT
FOURTEEN I ZERO NO THAT BILL
OUT. NOW MOVES FOLLOW NUMBER
EIGHT FILE ITEM EIGHT IS SB
FORCES TWO ABSENT. ALLEN HI
ALLEN FIVE BRADFORD HI CRUSH HI
WESO. I WAS SO HI THAT'S FOR
TWO ZERO TWO THAT'S BILLS I WAS
FOURTEEN IS NO THAT BILL OUT.
FILE ITEM TEN FILE I'M TEN SB
FIVE FOUR THREE- MEMBERS ALLEN
HI ALLEN HI BAKER. BRADFORD I
BRADFORD AYE THAT'S THEIR ZERO
TWO OF L. A. THIRTEEN EYES NAY
THE BILL'S- BOB A LOT OF NUMBER
ELEVEN. THIS IS FILE I MEAN S.
SEVEN TWO ONE ABSENT OUR HI. HI
BAKER. BRADFORD HI BRADFORD AYE
THAT'S THEIR ZERO GERMANS BILLS
OUT THIRTEEN I ZERO KNOWS THAT
BILL OUT. I REALLY TO TAKE THE
TO THANK. WHO WORKS IN THE PUB
TEST TODAY. IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE
TO TODAY PLEASE YOUR COM OR
SAID OF- TO THE COMMITTEE OR
TWO OR- YOUR COMMONSENSE ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION- WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA I APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY- IN THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- COMING HERE TODAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THIS
MEETING IS. THE GERMAN.